What that actually means
is that if there are two deck
lairs
lair
attribute, your app won't build.
So instead of declare ing
the
Android name space, you declare
your app one.  You do that via
this sin
syntax, and we know that's
sort of clumsy.  We just talked
about what they are, so let's
bout the difference and
how you actually use them.
So, themes, .  Themes are
total context, which is why it
take 20 methods.  One called set
points to style.  One thing to
note is that it's kind of a
badly named method in that it
doesn't set, it apply ies.  So
you'll already have a theme and
then when you call this method,
on top.  And then
you have a get theme, which will
your manifest, internally, all
that does is just before your is
for you.  So it's exactly the
same as the APIs with calling.
Now, themes don't actually
do anything.  I like to think of
big configuration stores
stores.  Let's take a look at
things which are
actually in there and what b
kind of configuration themes are
in there.  The first thing is
default widget styles.  When you
create a widget, it will have a
default style for it and the way
style is in your theme.  Each
different widget has a different
text is called edit style.  Text
is called text style.  You get
the idea.  But, yeah, that's the
color views.
Alan is going to talk about
they're basically mini styles
which affect only text.  Now,
this is where I think the bulk
of stuff is in themes an that is
window is create ed for you
internally and that is where
your whole view hierarchy sits
and above that is a lot of
framework stuff so if you're
using an action bar, it will
inject a load of views for the
action bar.
And this is so all the
configuration value asks in your
it.
Then we have some drawables.
Wouldn't it be nice if we
brought in some off the shelf
handy drawables to use, and we
The most important I think
is select backgrounds.  That
will give you a really nice
draw
drawable to use as a view, a
background view.  It will give
you a highlight.
It will give you like a rip
ripple.  Before that, it's kind
of like a us.  And then lastly,
call theme session.  Alan's
about that later,
but basically there are
components laid to override the
theme and they'll pick it out
from your master theme.  Right,
so that's themes out of the way.
Let's talk about styles.
Styles do a lot.  They're
the things that do the bulk of
the work.  They're really handy
for decomposition of styles.
Let's look at an example.  So
here we have a view and we want
to reuse this background tag.
Now, this is kind of a trivial
you're only
reuse ing one thing.  You
wouldn't
use this, you would use three or
four but it's a bit of an
unwieldily example if we do
more
more.  So we're going to reuse
this.  Here's that style.  We'll
put in the attribute, that's the
name, and then we'll put our
value in it.  Now each value you
once we do that, we can go back
ur layout and swap the
Android background and replace
it with the style tech, pointing
they'll all be apply ied too.
A bit of a pro type e tip
for you, Android studio does
that nicely.  If you go to re
refactor style, it gives you a
nice little UI where you can
pull out attributes and do it
for you but the other good thing
views in your layout and then
automatically reuse the style.
It's pretty cool.  So hopefully
now you know the difference
between themes and styles, so
let's have a look at the
intricate           intrick
agency iys of -- intricacies of
create ing them.  Themes and
styles, it's handy when you're
two bit styles.
Important thing to know is that
they overlay.  There are a
couple of ways of using them.
The first is implicitly, so the
star before the preceding dot.
You can also do it
explicitly, and that's done for
the parent tack.  So here we've
got style called my button
style
style, and it sets an explicit
parent, and as you guessed, the
is what you set.  The ot here in
the explicit  of the implicit.
So you've got style here using
dot notation in the name but
also has the parent tack and the
explicit version always wins.
Now the really powerful
thing when using styles is that
you can reference values from
your theme and that's the
attribute thing we were talking
about earlier.  So here we go
back to our style we create ed
which sets a background.  And
instead of using that, we want
to use the backgrounds which we
talked about earlier which is
that nice clickable highlight.
So this thing looks a little bit
mark
mark.  Now, that denotes that
we're going to be doing a theme
looker.
The second bit, the Android
colon is the name space we're
going to be looking up.  So if
you're using a custom attribute,
you can put whatever name space.
Then we have/, that denotes the
thing we're going to be looking
at.  We only have one type,
which is actress, you can
actually submit this.  And then
we have the last part which is
the actual name of the attribute
we're going to be looking up.
Now, like I said, the type
is optional.  The access slash
only      o
omniscient.  It works the same.
Now we have Alan.
>> ALAN VIVERETTE: Thanks,
Chris.  Chris just gave you the
overview of what is a theme,
what is a style, and how do you
create them?  So we're going to
go hands on with some of the and
what we have as
the building blocks and how we
apply these in practice.  So
first we have themes.  Themes in
Android are fixed with theme
dot
dot.  In material, it's theme
dot material.  So everyone
familiar with these.
We have the material dark theme,
special things like give you a
dark action baron
bar on top of a
light theme.  It's just a huge
bag of attributes for colors,
window attributes, things like
that.  We also have overlay
themes that define a subset of
values that as Chris mentioned,
get apply ied on top of your
existing theme.  So for example,
term.light contains only the
colors relevant for a light
theme.  It's not going to change
initiative your window attribute
attributes.  For people who are
developing for older platforms,
you may have noticed on API 21
and 22 that if you set a color
accent for your theme and open a
dying original on API 21 and 22,
you're still going to get teal,
unless you explicitly define
something that redefines that
color.  In API 23, we added a
dialogue theme.  It gets
apply ied
on top of your activity theme so
the host they've creates the
dialogue, we apply window
accents on top that have so your
color accent, anything you set
to that gets propagate ed to
dialogue on API 23 and above.
Overall theme looks like
this, again, it's just a subset
of the thing that's would have
been define ed in the overall
material or light themes.  Can
you create these yourself very
materially and just use theme.
your activity.  Material theme
also spec defines a number of
text experiences.  So for larger
text, you change the opacity of
buttons.  You may set all caps.
experience in material
experience .0.  These are just
sets of attributes specific to
text and either define ed in
your
theme with text appearance small
the Android: Text appearance
attributes so this is just going
ttribute
attributes to style your text.
We also have a number of
default widget styles, so these
are prefixed with widget.templet
they're going to implement
things you recognize from the
material spec, to, for example,
we've added a seek bar.discreets
your seek bar.  You can check  d
emos for a along             for
a longer
example of some of the different
widget styles, but these you can
apply to your widgets with the
style attributes so style equals
set of attributes that are going
to ride defaults for views.  So
for example the seek bar
discreet has implicit
inheritance from the seek bar,
and we just redefine ed tick
mark
so we get those variables at
each progress point.
So while we're here,
anybody who's really dug into
the material theme may have
noticed something unusual about
our widget styles and this is
that the light themes and dark
themes are identical.  So our
themes typically just
inherit directly from the
default themes        themes and
don't re
redefine anything, but under
parent themes, so if
your activity is light or dark,
you're still going to get
correctly
correctly colored widgets.  How
do we do that?  Well, as Chris
mentioned, we have colors define
defined by the themes and we're
going to use these in the
widget
widgets so this allows
allows really
high level.  Everybody should be
material.  This gives a little
pop-up in various plaices, the
foreground borderless color
buttons, radio buttons, et
cetera.  And one example of how
to implement this.  So, for the
colored button that we just
showed, we have a background
that points to a drawable.  In
that drawable, which is just a
ripple wrapping around a shape,
we actually don't use PNGs
anymore, we have a tent and that
tent points to a color state
list.  And that color state list
a disable ed
statement the enabled state
points to colored access so when
you see that color button, the
default color is going to be
color action tent on a white
shaped drawable wrapped with a .
So let's talk a little bit
bout theme ed colors.  We
also have foreground and
background colors so these are
going to be white and black or l
y     ively for the white and
dark themes.  What good does
that do us?  You may not be
using flat black or white in
your application a L. well,
lot.  Well,
let's take the switch, for
example.  We could have define
ed
theme attributes for switch fore
foreground, switch background,
all basically
variations on white or black.
the XML for this.
The switch is define ed as a
round
-- again, we don't really use
PN
PNGs.  In the enabled -- sorry,
in the disable ed state, this is
going to inherit the disable ed
alpha from the theme which vary
theme and it's going to use the
foreground color.  So in the
dark theme, you have a dropped
alpha version of white.  This is
wreck that already has a
capacity so we're going to end
up with everything being a
slight variation on the fore
foreground color.  And you can
very easily use this in your own
going to be consistent with your
theme.  We also have text colors
colors, as Chris mentioned.
So we have a primary text
color which is used to provide
very high contrast for things
user needs to be looking at
immediately.  We have secondary
color which is just a dropped
apes capacity and follow the
material spec so I believe 84
and 56 percent of    opacity and
also have inverse versions of
these which we don't use much
but if you're going to be
displaying content against your
accent color, text inverse is a
great way to do that.
We also have color accent
primary dark which we added in
material and are going to
provide your branding materials
so if you're pulling in color
accent, you get that color pop,
you'll probably want to use
color primary inverse on top of
that so in a white theme, you'll
Val dark accent.  In a white
have a dark accent
and you can pull these into your
We also have control normal
and activate ed.  Control normal
is great and I really recommend
everybody use this if you have
icons.  So, for example, check
boxes are going to use color
normal by default.  If you're
pulling content into your accent
going to be the exact right
opacity, and the number of times
s different by like 5
5 percent alpha, it kills me .
So please use color
normal.
So, looking at example from
API demos, you can probably
guess how a lot of these widgets
primary, we have that switch
below it, which is color
secondary.  We have the accent
color in the activate ed state
for
our check boxes and radio
button
buttons and we have the color
background as our overall
background.  Color backgrounds
floating as our card background.
So, you can look at a screen
shot of something or look at an
application and probably guess
where a lot of the colors are
coming from.  So now we have an
overview of what's available to
us and how these are used to
build the framework and style
and how we can apply these to
our applications.
These are very powerful
powerful
tools in Android and theme
attributes are especially
power
powerful starting in API 21.  So
color state lists and theme
attributes to tint your drawa
ble
drawables so you can specify
color control highlight for your
ripple, which is what we have as
the default, and you can specify
color state list as a tint or
color for XML define ed shapes
so
if you like to step away from
using PNGs all the time, maybe
you have a bunch of different PN
press a button and get a
different color.  Color state
lists support theme attributes
starting in the next API
version
version, 22.  This means that
you can start pulling in the
foreground color, the accent
color, setting in the alpha to
match the theme in your color
state list which is going to
again, sheep you step away from
having drawable selectors or
individual PNGs for all of your
.  App       AppCompat also
supports
color state lists.  Starting in
24, you can use something to
read theme attributes from your
color state XML.  It does this
automatically
automatically, internally, and
you can do this at run time for
specific XML files.  We also
support view tinting.  So what
this means is for views that own
drawable assets, things like the
thumb in a switch, the track in
a progress bar, you can tint
these either from layout XML or
at runtime.  So, for example,
switch has a thumb and a track
and because it's a view, it also
have separate XML attributes
that you can use to set a tint.
is a really powerful way to tint
just a oneoff somewhere within
your layout        layout so you
need the
switch to be read, you can make
it read really easily, you need
it read with a disable ed state,
As I mentioned, we have a
bunch of text in the material
state bag.  You can apply these
using Android text  you can re
apply
these at run time which is tomb
something unusual for Android.
So for most views, styles get
apply ied once.  For text views,
you can restyle them at runtime
whenever you need to using set
text experience which takes a
style that should be a text
experience or something that
inherits from a text experience,
All right, so we've learned
some cool things about what's
available to us for create ing
styles and create ing theme draw
drawables.  How can we play this
to do something kind of cool?
Well we introduced the day/night
support library and
this is something we've support
resource qualifier.  This
existed since API eight.  in API
23, this is
something that any application
can toggle through API manager.
So if you write an application
and you want to toggle the
global state of night mode, you
just go into UI manager and you
can set night mode.  When that
changes, it's going to be
treated as a configuration
change.  Which adds the land
file.  If your
user either prefers dark or if
you want to set it up for
automatic where at nighttime
they'll see'      see a dark
theme and
daytime they'll see a light
theme.
So the actual implement
implementation on this rely ies
on
inheritance so we specify a day/
day/night theme.  The only
difference is the parent that
we're inheriting from.  Under
not night, or the default
qualifier, we're going to to
inherit it from theme.material
lights and under the light
qualifier we're going to inherit
r when we have the resource
application change the
application is going to get an
on configuration chaining and
we're going to reload using this
new parent, which means
everything that we inflate is
going to have different theme
colors.
Now you can also define
explicit colors so if you want
to have a hard-coded color and
define that differently under
night or not night, you can do
that, but it's easier to rely on
either dark or light resources
and in custom widgets you made
where you're using theme
attributes you're just going to
automatically get the right
colors so you don't have to do a
lot of work between implementing
dark and light theme.
As Chris mentioned
yesterday, this has been back
port the to API 15 through
AppCompat so if you want to
implement a light and dark theme
switch that will toggle
night mode.
So using themes and
attributes can help simplify the
visual present
presentation of your a
pplication
application, but what if you
want to change just a small
portion of presentation in your
application?  So we know that
theme.material can make your
application look dark.  We know
that theme.materiallight can
make your application look
light
light.  But what if you want to
have something like a dark
action bar but the rest of your
application be light?  Well,
there's one way you could do
this.  You could use the light
activity light theme, and then
just specify everything in your
action bar manually to be dark.
That's a little complicate ed,
so
maybe instead we'll have a dark
theme and we'll just manually
specify everything in our
activity, you'll        all of
our content to
be a different color.  That ends
being really tricky, so
please don't do that.  Don't
hard-code text colors.  So
there's an easier way.
And that is through overlay
themes and specifying themes on
portions of your view hierarchy.
dark action bar theme.  So we
actually redefine the theme
that's used for the ToolBar
section of your application.  So
theme that pulls in light
colors
colors, we have a dark theme
that pulls in dark colors.  And
these are implemented using the
Android theme attribute from XML
the layout inflate er and it's
going to replace our overlay,
the theme used to inflate a sub
subsection of your view
hierarchy.  And the actual
implementation here is pulling
the theme attribute from your XM
context theme wrapper which is
exactly what it sounds like.  We
going to inflate all the child
content against this new wrapped
effectively is the dark theme in
the section of layout that has
equals dark and verybody else.
actual implementation
of this rely ies on the default
layout that we provide for an
activity that has an action bar.
X
XML files in the Android  screen
action is what
we inflate if you request an
action bar in your activity and
we're going to set the Android
theme attribute to inherit from
the action bar theme attribute
define ed in your theme.  Which
has attribute and theme a lot of
this theme section.  So we're
going to pull in the dark theme
on top of the light activity
theme.  We've define ed actions
bar theme in the dark action bar
theme as material.dark.actionbar
material.dark.actionbar.  This
is the dark overlay which pulls
in the dark theme colors.  It
switches the text foreground and
bar sets up a couple of things
for displaying the -- let's see,
But the important part is that
we're pulling in dark colors on
top of your base ed light theme.
We also redefine the pop-up
theme so that you get a light
pop-up on top of a dark action
baron top of a light activity so
out on top of each other.
We also support Android
.
Android.theme through the
AppCompat library, so this is
going to go all the way back to
API 17, and the inherit is going
to work on API 11 and above.
What this means is if you put is
will apply it to that view only,
on API 11 and above, we will
apply it to all of the views
that are inflated as a child of
that view. Chris is going to c
over
some common mistakes that
developers make when using theme
themes and styles., Alan.
So as Alan said, we're now going
things we see quite a lot both
in Google apps and also external
able to stop repeat myself
because we see this a lot and we
the first thing we're going to
go through is using the
incorrect stall parent.  So it's
go through an
example and show you what we can
actually do.  So here we have an
edit text, and what we want to
do is make sure every text has
the medium font.  So what we're
going to do is change the
default style to edit text and
then set it to have a medium
font.  So here as an example and
here's our style.  O our style
here is my edit view, could be
whatever you want, but set to
one thing, and set to medium.
Once you've done that we'll then
reference it in our theme so it
gets picked up as default and
then you run your app and you
see this.
Suddenly, all your edit
text is gone.  You've lost all
your style ing.  No longer
edit
editable.  But you have changed
ont to medium.  The reason is
happens is that you set a parent
on the style
style.  And what that happens,
is that you no longer pick up
all of the system defaults so
you no longer get the background
it's editable, all sort of weird
and random things that are in
style.  The way you fix it is
just set the correct parent.
The best way to figure out what
the parent is is just look at
what you're inheriting from.  It
But quite nieces        nicely
space ed out,
grouped together, not too hard
to read.  And suddenly, once you
again
again.
Now, this is quite a
technical mistake.  You're only
going to this if you're kind of
writing custom views but it's
the difference between default
style atra and default style rez
this.  The main trace e place
-- place
you're going to use this is
obtained style attributes.  You
can see default state attr and
default style res and the
problem is default style attr
should always point to an attr.
from, but the last one,
default style res should point
to an actual resource, so an
actual style resource.  If you
mix them up, basically, things
stop working.  Now following on
from that,
there's an intricacie
intricacies in how obtain style
actually works.  So when you're
trying to read a set of
attributes, this is the order it
goes through.  So the first
thing is looks four is the value
That's what contains all the
attributes which are set on your
layout and you've set Android
background on it, it will be
contained in the attribute.  The
second thing it looks for is the
same value within any use er
style
so if you're using the style
tab
tab, it will look in there.  The
third thing is looks for is in
the default style res so that's
in the actual concrete pointer
to the default style.  Last
thing is looks at is attribute,
the default style theme, and
then finally
it looks at base
value theme.  Now, please don't
do this.  Using default
attribute themes.  This is a
mistake which someone in our
team made.  So here we have a
theme and we set the Android
background on it.  Now Android
background is something you use
in the view, but here it's set
in the theme.
Going back to obtained
obtained s, the last
thing
is looks for is the theme.  So
basically because you've set it
in the theme, any user will go
to this.  So if you set a  your
theme, I
don't know, pink, every view
which does not have this parent
have a pink background.
That's a really big mistake we
see quite often.
Now, we are going to post
more of these mistakes in a b
log
blog, so follow us.  L. that's
it.  Hopefully you've learned
stuff about themes and   Thank
you very much.
(
Presentation ended at
11:37 a.m. CST)
********
This text is being provided in a
Access Realtime Translation
(CART) is provided in order to
facilitate communication
accessibility and may not be a
totally verbatim record of the
proceedings.
********
>
>>
>> Ox,
>> 5/18/16.
>> How is everyone doing today?
Is everyone super excited about
the new
Firebase.  That sounds kind of
exciting like 9:00 a.m. excited.
Let's be 6:00 p.m. concert
excited.  How excited are you?
(Cheers)
That's better.  So I'm here
today to talk about two things.
Those two things are real time
and off line.  It's kind of
funny when you talk about real
time and off line together
because they are kind of
opposites because real time is a
fresh stream of data, and off
line is data we usually get
served from a stale cache.
So getting them together is not
that easy, and trust me, I know.
I once failed at a start up d
oing just this.  My start up's
name was kale.
And we will one mission.  That
was to change the world.  And we
were going to do that by
building a collaborative grocery
list app.  And if it was going
to be world changing, then it
needed to be in real time and it
needed to work off line.  So
when we went to build our app we
started with the back end and
we were like, okay, we need a
server.  That's makes sense and
then we need a database because
we have to store data, so let's
do that.  Then we had to build a
real time wire protocol and
then there is more than one
device.  So we had to build a s
ynchronizing method so we could
talk to all devices in
real t ime.  And then after
that went off line and went back
to on line state.  We had to
send the data back to the
server, to the database and
update clients in real time.
So like a year later we
realized, oh, my God, we haven't
even built an app!  So we built
an Android app an IOS app and
web app and the chrome team was
like you only need to build a
progressive web app.  We were
like I'm sorry, we can't do t
hat.  They are like why?  We
were like we ran out of money.
So building a real time offline
app didn't have to be this hard.
Because we could have used
Firebase.  So Firebase is a
suite of integrated products
designed to help you develop
your app, grow your user base
and earn money.  Today I'm hear
to talk to you about the
Firebase real time  database.
The Firebase real time database
helps you build real time in off
line apps.  The way is works is
every single time one device
sends an update to the server,
that update is synchronized
across all devices within
milliseconds.  Today I'll cover
how you can store data in real
time or store data and how to
retrieve the data in real time
and then saving data and then
handling offline conditions.
So let's start with storing
data.  So you saw when I had my
startup we had this build
complex back end structure and
we were responsible for building
this, maintaining it and
hosting it.  Well, if we would
have used Firebase, we wouldn't
have had this problem because
the real time database is Cloud
host.  What that means is you
don't have to build it, you
don't have to maintain it, you
don't have to host it.  All you
do is build the app and the real
time database will do the rest.
So how is data stored in this
database?  Well, it's just a
tree of lists and objects.  So
if you understand what lists are
and objects are and trees then
you know how to store data.
Let's take a visualization.
This here is the root of a tree.
We create a branch that will
be a list of grocery items.  And
then in this list, we can have
a set of items that all have v
alues that are a
grocery list.  Now, if you
stare at this structure really
hard, you might notice something
familiar.  That's that this is
just JSON.  The real time
database is one big JSON object
you can manage in real time.  If
you are familiar with JSON
that's how you store data in the
real time database.  We call in
a no no S QL JSON database.  To
a lot of people coming from an
SQL background, they ask me a
similar question.  How go
I take the JSON data and fit it
for my app.  There is one rule
of thumb you can follow.  That
is you can structure your data
after your
view.
What this means is if our data
struck fur is a list of  grocery
items and our app is a rosary
list app we can take these v
alues and we just map them onto
the view.
And when you have it set up like
this, it makes it really easy
to read your data in real time.
So let's see how he we can use
the real time database to
synchronize data across multiple
devices.  This was my, this was
the way we did our back end
with Kahhle.  It wasn't great.
We never mastered real time.
What we would do is accepted a
request to our back end and get
a response and we could render
an item.  And while that was
just great for one device, the
other device has no idea
anything has happened at all.
Because we don't have a
connection from the database to
this device.  So it's always
left in the dark to any
changes.  The real time
database though has a
persistent connection to every
single device so when data
changes it knows what devices to
send that data  to.
And we can do this using the
real time database SDK.  So the
SDK works on Android,  IOS and
JavaScript.  With this
one line code you can create I
connection to your database.
This is more than a connection.
This database reference class
it  gives us a plot of control.
This database references are a
handle to an object or a list.
When you create a reference to
this piece of data, you have
control over it.  And it allows
you to read this data in real
time.
So the first reference you
usually create is the root
reference because you are
pointing at all of the data in
your database and likely you
don't want to read all of the
data in your database because
you are a smart person and you
only want to read just a subset.
So let's say we want to get
the grocery items.  To do that,
I can create this child
reference.  I can pass in the
key of my grocery items.  Now, I
have access just to that list.
And using real time events, I
can stream the data in real t
ime.  The two events I will
cover today are value events and
child events.
So the way value events work is
you can attach them to the
database reference and so what
you are essentially saying is
every single time data changes
in this location, send me an
update.  And we can receive this
update through a call back.
And this call back is fired with
a data snapshot which is our
synchronized data set.  And it's
really important to understand
that we are  synchronizing
application state.  We are not
just sending back updates.  And
to understand what that really
means I set up this little debug
station.  So the top we are
just assigning a value event
listener to your grocery list
and then below we will be
logging the results to this
console.  So the first log from
the database is going to be our
list of items.  So we could take
this list and we can just
display on the view.
Now, legits say the user comes
in and adds the item of coffee.
What do you think is going to
happen inside on data change.
So you might think that, well,
we added an item of coffee, we
are going to get that new item
back on data change.  But that's
not exactly what's going to
happen.  What's going to happen
is we are going to get the
entire list including the newly
added item.  That's because this
is our synchronized application
state.  It's the true state of
our list.
You might think that kind of
sounds inefficient that if I
just add an item I download the
entire set, well, the real time
database SDK is a little bit
smarter than that.  What it
tries to do is it tries to take
delta events from the server and
instead of only taking the item
that was added and piecing that
together with our local state.
So it becomes bandwidth
conscious.  So value events are
a way for you to synchronize the
entire value of an object or a
list when anything changes.
But sometimes you want a bit
more control.  You may not want
to get the entire object or list
back, and you might just want
to get one thing at a time.  So
I might want to know when only
items are added or if items have
been deleted so I can display a
fancy animation.  So that's
where we can use child events.
So child events are similar to
value events in the sense that
we can attach them to a
reference, but they provide us
with more than one type of call
back.  We can tell when things
have been added to our list,
when the item's value has
changed, and we can even tell
when something has been
removed.  See how this works?  I
have the same debug screen up.
The first event that gets fired
is the child added event.
And this gets fired for every
item one at a time that's
existing in this list.  So I
will first see it for each item
at a time.  So as I go through,
we add an item and we render it
to the view.  So this gives us
single control one at a time,
and let's say we go and we want
to remove an item.  So if a user
goes and swipes an item off a
list, this will fire off child
removed.  And what this will do
is when this fires off, it fires
off on every connected device.
So every device knows how to
remove
this item # R.  Let's say we
change one item and we want
coffee and more coffee.  It will
fire off child changed and we
get a call back and we know this
is the item that needs to be
changed in our list.
So this is a lot of events and
these provide you a lot of
control of how you synchronize
your data.  But sometimes you
will find yourself writing a lot
of boilerplate code to get this
to work with common components
on your platform.  So that's why
for Android and IOS we built
Firebase UI.  What Firebase UI
does is takes these dks
references and pair -- database
references and pairs them with a
recycler view on Android.  You
can take this database reference
pass it to the Firebase recycle
adapter class and every time an
event fires off we will serve
that change and bind it to your
view holder.  So it handles all
of the eventing for you.
And if you are an iOS developer
it does the same with UI table
views.  Every time something
changes, it takes the change and
binds it to the UI table view
cell.  And if you are a web fan,
we have integrations with
pretty much every JavaScript
framework whether it's angular,
polymer, Amber or react, we have
integrations is that work with
your style of
flow.  So that's how you
retrieve data in real time.
That's only part of the puzzle.
To trigger real time events,
you have to know how to save
data.
So how would we add an item to
our grocery list.  We know that
the initial reference points to
the entire database, and that if
you create a child, it points
to just the piece of the
database, just the list.  Well,
we can again go and create
another child from that list.
And that gives us an object that
we can save a value to.
So in this case, we are creating
a child underneath the list, so
a new grocery item, and we are
giving it a key saying it's the
second item and giving it a
value of coffee.  The way this
works is that when one item
sends this update to the real
time database, it's going to
trigger a real time event for
each connected device, and then
we are going to render that
device or render that item onto
the view.  This is what your
data flow looks like with the
real time database.  You save
items and trigger real time
events.  And so we
can keep our entire application
state in sync just through this
pattern.
But sometimes there can be an
issue.  Let's say the other
device goes and they also add an
item using that same key of
item underscore 2.  Well, that's
going to trigger a real time
event, but it's going to delete
the item of eggs, and it's going
to add the item of coffee.
That's because we use the same
key name.  And what this is
called is a collision.  So we
are colliding by using the same
key name.  And the real time
database SDK has a simple way of
fixing
this.  So we will go back and
create our grocery list
reference, and then rather than
creating an explicit child, we
are going to call this method
called push.  And you can think
about it if it was an array and
you are pushing a new item onto
the array because what we are d
oing is creating a new item onto
our list in real time.
But this item we create, it has
a unique identifier.  And this
way when we use this, we know
that we will not be  colliding
with any items that exist in the
database.  And when you know
that you are not going to have
collisions, it sets you up to
work off
line.  So when we were building
Kahhle, we had service problems
off line.  We were a grocery
list app and people would go to
the rosary store and it turns
out grocery stores are known for
having pretty bad connections.
So they couldn't even use their
app in the store.  So when we
went to fix this, we ran into an
issue by the fact that real
time or that offline really
manifests itself in more than
one way.  So the real time
database handles offline in two
ways.  The first is intermittent
offline.  This works for every
single platform or Android, web,
iOS, and this is like if you go
into an elevator or a tunnel
for a short period of time and
your connection drops, well, the
real time database SDK puts a
local in-memory cache on your
device so if the connection
drops, we can serve these
changes through this cache.  So
it will work off line just as it
did on line.
Sometimes you might be going off
line for a bit longer.  And you
might be getting often an
airplane, going through a hike
in  in the wilderness or you
might be spending a long time in
the grocery store.  In these
cases you are likely going to
turn off your phone, restart the
app, and when you do this, it
will clear that in-memory cache.
The real time database has a
simple way of fixing this for
Android and  iOS.  What it
allows you to do is in one line
of code, you can enable a
persistent cache on your device.
goes off line and they clear out
of the app, their data will
still live on the device.  What
happens when they go on line and
what happens if they were using
the app when they went off line
and they were writing to the
database, like what happens t
hen?  Well, the device as we
know, stores this data in a
persistent cache and when it
goes online it sends the data to
the real time database and that
merges the changes on the
server and sends a merged update
to every device so everyone
request get back onto -- can get
back onto the same page.
That's how you do real time and
offline.  I wanted to talk a bit
about security.  Because we are
writing all of our code on the
client.  So how do we keep
everything secure?  Well, the
real time database comes with a
set of security rules which are
a declarative way to say who has
access to what pieces of data,
and this integrates with
Firebase authentification.  So
you can log in users and secure
data against them.  And we are
not going to go into detail with
this was Jacob Wenger an hour
ago gave a talk about Firebase
and security.  If you want to
see it you should check out the
You Tube channel we launched the
other day where all of the I/O
videos will be on and a series
of screen casts called fire c
asts which will
teach you everything you need to
do to get started with the new
Firebase.  Tomorrow, you should
check out zero to app where four
c olleagues will get on stage
and live code the sa same a.m.
on iOS web, integrating with
Firebase off and Firebase and
Firebase storage.  So in this
talk we covered storing data,
retrieving in real time, storing
data and handling off line
conditions.  So now you know how
to use the real time database
to, does now, you know how to
use the real time database to
build real time apps with
Firebase.  If you build
something, I would love to know
about it.  So you can get
started and send me a screen
shot, a gist or whatever of what
you built and I would love to
take a look at it.  So that is
what we have for today, but for
more information on Firebase,
you can check out our office
hours or head over to our
Firebase tents and we would love
to answer your questions, and
just know that when you build
with the real time database, you
are getting the best of both
worlds, 6 both real time and off
line..  Thank you guys very m
uch!
both real time and off line..
>>
SDK
for droid
for Android:  A tech
deep dive
Tech Deep Dive
.
Doug
Stevenson.
>> #01: Time a developer
I'm today can her
.   we'll sit
down.  In this talk we'll
cover dynamic links.  As you
know by now, these are part of
Firebase.  Firebase is a suite
of products that help you
develop your app, grow your user
base and earn money.  And in
this talk we'll help you use
dynamic links to make your
marketing URLs much more
effective.  So dynamic links are
mobile deep links that work
like you always wanted them to.
Once upon a time you all
you URL used to be really
easy.  You click on them and go
to a Web page.  Then people
began using deep links, which
linked directly into an app.
They actually enable some very
nice experience.  You could
click on a link on a mobile Web
page, and it could take you
directly into an app where you
could make the reservation right
there from the app without
losing any contact.  Here is the
problem:  If you want to
provide the best experience when
a link is clicked, that
depended on quite a few things.
For example, if the link was
clicked, was the app installed?
If the app was installed, how
the app gets open depends on
which flat form and which I/O S
version.  If it's Android 9, you
could be opening deep links.
If it happened to be clicked on
an older platform, you have to
use a custom scheme or something
else.  Even if it was a newer
platform, like in I/O S9, if the
link was in a web view, web
views don't       don't have
universal links.  It depends on
the app that contains it.  If
the app was not installed, you
have to make a choice.  Do I
install the app or take them to
mobile web view.  Even that
depends on where the user is
coming from and what they're
doing.  So this can get a little
complicated.
When they install the app and
open it, the apoowe you have
lost all
app -- the app loses all
context.  We created dynamic
links to solve.  Let's have him
come up and explain how it.
>> Thanks for delivering all the
sad, depressing news.  We have
dynamic links.  These are
basically links that behave the
way you want them to by
intelligently changing their
behavior based on what's
what's going on on your user's
device.  So including things
like what platform they're on,
and whether they have the app
installed or not.  And most
importantly, they can retain
that link information through
the app store installation
process so that when users open
your app for the first time, you
could still get information
about the link that brought the
user to your app in the first
place.  And to demonstrate why
that's important, let's show you
a little example here.  This is
John and Mary.  They have a
recess pie              a recess
a r     a recipe app.
They want to promote it to
their current apps through an
e-mail campaign.  They decide
they'll run a little e-mail
campaign.  It looks like this.
They got some lovely pictures.
And then they want to add some
try out or app buttons.  They
write in the e-mail, hey, check
it out on Android and check it
out on I/O S.  Great
idea                 OS.  Great
idea.  For starters, we need
these two buttons, one to get
people to the app store and one
to get people to the Play Store.
It's sort of twice the
ugliness, and you also have the
issue of what happens if your
IOS user accidently clicks the
green button and goes to the
Play Store.  They'll get
confused and not follow through
on the e-mail.
There are issues around
analytics and measuring, like
how many people are actually
clicking on these links?  And
are the people that are getting
into your app through this
e-mail campaign, are they
actually valuable users?  Are
they more valuable than, perhaps
, people who found the app
organically?  Are they
vegetarian users more or less
valuable than the dessert
people?  How could you measure
this?  These are all the typical
an lyticstuff you want to
analytic stuff.
The operation for the app will
be the same for all users.
Whether they went to the app
either through the vegetarian
e-mail blast or through the kink
y concoctions.  It would be
It would be kind of a
crappy experience for your
vegetarian user who says oh,
this looks like a fun app.  They
go into the app and the very
first thing they get are recess
pies             recipes for
stake     pork shops.  They
never come back to it.
Luckily, for our presentation,
this is the kind of thing
dynamic links are used for.
Let's look at how we would could
not construct one of these if
we would          we were
building the URL by hand.  For
starters, all dynamic links will
start off with this kind of
domain.  You've got a little sub
domain.  You'll inside A, B, C,
D, E, is the unique code
associated with your app.  That
creates       gets created for
you when you create an app in
Firebase
.  This is the link parameter.
We'll talk a little more later
about how you actually get this
information, but it's important
to know that this is sort of the
important information that your
app is going to read in.  It
also kind of plays double duty.
If a user opens this dye no,
ma'am I can link on
this
dynamic link, on an unsupported
such      such a non-Android or
IOS phone, they would go to this
link.
Next we would add the packaging.
This is basically so we can
direct your Android users to the
entry for your app on the Play
Store.  Similarly, we would add
in the app store so you would
know where to send in your app
installed.  Then we'll add the
campaign tracking using UTM
tags.  If you've done any kind
of Play Store tracking or Google
an lit beings           alytics
, maybe this looks familiar to
you.  Essentially you could
think of as a hierarchal way of
representing your marketing
campaign.  So you have this uber
campaign and then within that
you'll have mediums that sort of
represent different places
where these campaigns exist,
like in an e-mail or in a QR
code or what have you.  And then
sort of you can drill down from
there.
So that ends up with an awfully
large link.  Luckily, we do have
a URL short inner that can
shorten this for you.  Although
both of these, I suppose, are
fine if you are putting them in
the tag of an e-mail.
And we also have a place on the
Firebase console where you can
create these links yourself if
they're nontechnical members of
your team who aren't
aren't super excited about URL
escaping and stuff.  So you can
add this in yourself, select
your apps from the drop-down
list, and it will generate the
large dynamic link or the
shortened version for you.  But
you can always use that expanded
format if you want to create
these links dynamically.  For
instance, you might want to
create links dynamically on your
client, and you can do that
just by sort of building up
these URLs like we showed
earlier.
So what happens when a user
clicks on this link?  Well, if
they have the app installed,
they'll be taken right into the
app; right?  And then at that
point the dynamic link will be
passed into your app.  Firebase
analytics will automatically
read in all of those UTM
tracking codes and make sure it
gets recorded properly.  And
then that link parameter will
get passed into your app to get
processed and do whatever it
wants to with it.
If the user does not have the
app installed, then we will take
your user to either the Play
Store or the app store
App Store         App
Store, depending on what
platform they're on.  When they
click on that link
,
when they click on that link.
Then when the first time your
user opens up you the app,
Firebase dynamic links go out
go out and look for any
pending user for this
application.  If it finds any,
it will deliver it to your app.
At this point Firebase
analytics will process any UTM
tracking tags you would
you had associated with it.
Then that link parameter will
once again get passed into your
client app that it can deal with
however it sees fit.
So where does this get us?
After creating this giant link?
Well, for starters, we only
need one button.  So that kind
of deals with issue number one.
We don't       don't have to
worry about our user clicking on
the wrong version or anything
like that.  It looks a little
nicer.  You know, in spite of my
crappy art skills.
But what about tracking where
users are coming from?  So
Firebase dynamic links will
automatically let you know how
many users clicked on any
individual link.  We can see the
number of times all our various
e-mail campaign links got
clicked.  Is it getting us
quality users?  Is it users that
will actually do things like
sign up for the newsletter from
within the app or buy or make an
in-app purchase or subscribe to
the premium version, whatever
it is we want them to do to make
some money.  That's where --
that's when you can find out
with these attribute goes
with
these tags.  It lets you define
certain events in your app,
making an app purchase or
signing up for a newsletter or
sharing the app with your
friends, as the important
conversion events.  Then you can
look at any of these conversion
events and break it
break it out by all of the UTM
parameters that get passed in,
campaign, medium, type, and so
on.  This is all done
automatically for you.
So you can see are these e-mail
campaigns more or less
effective, not just in getting
us users, but users that then
share the app with their friends
?  And you know, how does this
compare users       versus users
who find it organically or by
other means.  You can use
Firebase analytics.  You can
find out prosecute           are
dessert fans spending more
money on our app than
vegetarians.  You can use that
using Firebase dynamic links and
you can decide which user is
more important for your app and
focus your attention on them.
issue none      number two.  So
how do we customize that warm
welcome?  That's what this link
parameter that we pass in
through these dynamic links.
You'll notice here we have this
URL that basically kinds
kind of looks like saying let's
show the user a welcome and
feature cakes or feature
vegetarian recipes.  Assuming we
have logic on our app to read
that in and customize that
initial set of recipes we showed
to our user, we can make sure
that users that went into our
app by clicking on the link in
our vegetarian are v   viddles
e-mail now get vegetarian
e-mail.  I know it looks like a
hamburger on the bottom left,
but it's a vegetable
it's a v
it's a vegie burger.
Trust me.
When they open up your app and
they kneeled get content that is
important and relevant to them;
right?  You know that whenever
app they clicked on was probably
important.  It was enough to
drive them to install your app
in the first place, so you can
kind of double down on that
information and make sure that
you present your users with
content that they care about
right away so that they don't
don't have to go digging
through your app to actually
find whatever content is
relevant to them.
So that's the sort of thing that
can really kind of increase
your attention and getting them
people coming back to your
app.  How does that link
parameter actually get passed
into your
code?  How can you kind of deal
with it?  We'll go into a few
implementation details.  On IOS
you'll be reading in a dynamic
link from you one of two
different ways, depending on
your situation.  You'll either
get this through a custom URL
scheme.  If you've never
implemented custom URL schemes
before, it's not too bad.
Basically what you do is over in
your info sexual create a new
URL type and you'll have your
URL type set to your bundle ID.
If you've added Google sign-in?
in in IOS app before, this
should look familiar to you.
Then within your application
open URL option goes they
had          method, you'll get
passed in that full dynamic
link.  You'll pass that off to
the Firebase dynamic links
library and basically ask it,
hey, can you take this URL and
turn it into a dynamic link
object?  You'll either get back
no, in which case it's URL
that's intended for Google sign-
in or Facebook sign-in and so on
, or you'll get back a dynamic
link object.  You can get that
link parameter by looking at the
URL property and your app is
can process it in whatever way
makes sense for your app.
The other way you'll get it
through universal links.  To get
that work being you'll need to
turn on the associated domains
capability within your ex
your X code project and
make sure the app.goo is listed.
It's okay to send universal
links to me through these
dynamic links.  Once again,
you're basically going to take
that URL that comes in, pass it
off to the dynamic links library
.  You'll get that can
back that final object in a
completion handler just in case
we have to make that one network
call to expand the short link
into a long link.
And then once we have that, we
have our link per tame
parameter and we can pass it
into our app and do whatever we
want to, analyze it, and figure
out what content we should be
displaying to our users.
By the way, don't       don't
freak out about universal links.
If you're like I haven't set
this up for my sight yet, it's
on my to-do list, you don't
you don't need to set up
universal links for your own web
side     site to get Firebase
dynamic links working.  You have
to set it up on the client
because we're sending you
universal links that we have
created that just serves your
dynamic links.  If you want more
information about this, I'm
doing a whole information on
Firebase for IOS developers
today.  You can check that out
for more information.  A
shameless bluing        plug.
This is one strategy which takes
advantage of app links.  Now
I'll preface this section by
saying I'm the IOS guy.
Probably most of you will
understand this part better than
me.  Here we go.  I'll try it
anyway.  First off, you'll set
up app links or if you're on
earlier versions of Android
intent filters for the URLs that
your app can handle.  This is
basically your way of telling
Android to automatically
recreaked           redirect
certain earls to
certain URLs within my
app, my app can handle these.
When you do this, Google Play
Services is smart enough to look
at any of the in    incoming
dynamic links.  They realize if
that link parameter equals an
app link for which your app is
already registered, it will sort
of do the work for you.  It
will open up the app to the
appropriate activity based on
this link parameter.  You still
need to do a little bit of work
on your client.  First off,
you're going to need to call Git
invitation
in the on-create part of your
app.  This is pending dynamic
things      links that might not
have been passed on to your app
because it wasn't installed.
If your user installed your app
because of a dynamic links, then
they open it up.  You would
call Git invitation
Invitation to read in
the dynamic links.  The part
that's highlighted there
basically says go ahead and
automatically go to whatever
part of my app, whatever
activity that link parameter
would have normally sent me to.
Basically in this call back you
don't           you don't need
to do anything.  We're printing
out some debug information.
On the other hand, if your app
is running and Google Play
Services has already directed
them to the appropriate activity
in your app, that's great.  You
are going to to want to call
Git invitation
Invitation
Git Invitation in
that link activity to consume
that information from Google
Play Services and make sure it
doesn't get called again in the
future.
Don't
Don't freak out about app links
either.  If you don't
you don't have app links set up
for your app, that is totally
fine as well.  You'll just need
to do       to do the work
yourself to kind of take in that
link parameter and parse it and
not leave it up to Google Play
Services to figure it out for
you.
Android people, did that make
sense?  All right.  I'm getting
the thumbs up.  Good.  Thank
you.
So my only question is what's
what's a manifest file?
Just kidding.  I know that much.
We got some successful e-mail
campaigns going.  In fact, now
one of our favorite bloggers,
grilling with Jill
Grilling With Jill
decided thepts      she wants to
put links right from the blog.
That sounds like a great idea
for dynamic links.  Imagine, you
click on the link for a recipe
and Firebase dynamic links sends
you directly to the recipe
within the autopsy
awesome.  If they don't
don't have the app installed, we
could also send them to the
Play Store or the App Store.
Isn't       Isn't this fantastic
?  This is going to send us all
these new users and this could
be the beginning of a beautiful
referral program.
So they send all these dynamic
links off to Grilling With Jill.
She address them in their
in her various posts.
Imagine everyone's  's shock
when the next day people
aren't               people
aren't quite happy with the
experience; right?  So here's
's the deal:  If you have some
kind of obvious, why not try
this in our app sort of button,
it's fine for that to take
people directly to the an store
or the Play Store
to the App Store or Play Store.
People are generally expecting
that to happen when they click
on a button like that.  But
people are probably not
expecting this kind of
experience if they're clicking
on something that looks like it
should just be taking them to
another website.  You've
probably surprised them in a bad
way and you get the not quite
happen              quite happy
emoji.  One way you could
address this is by adding fall
back parameters to your dynamic
links.  This basically tells the
device that instead of going to
the Play Store or App Store,
why not take the user to another
Web page that you have
specified.
So it basically looks like this
when you're construct you go the
giant dynamic links.
You can add fall back for
Android, another one for other
devices.  They don't       don't
have to be.  We can direct them
to different fallback pages
with different screen shots and
different device shots, which is
always nice.  If recipe
Wrangler               Recipe
Wrangler has the fallback page
for IOS.  It kind of depends.
fallback pages who still have
Recipe Wrangler installed, we'll
directly go there.  For those
that don't       don't, it will
go
to whatever fall back     back
page they specify.  If it's also
available on the website, we
can kind of show the Web page
directly within the device.  But
we can also maybe send them to
a marketing page that tells them
a little bit more about Recipe
Wrangler and how awesome it is
and you should install and that
sort of thing.  Then within this
button, which now definitely
looks like it should
be              it should be
paying                     it
should be taking you to the App
Store or Play Store, we can add
in another Firebased dynamic
link where we don't       don't
have the fallback link specified
and take the user to the App
Store or Play Store so they can
go ahead and install the app.
We give these to our Grilling
With Jill blogger and we're back
in action.  We still get the
benefit of using dynamic links
by seeing how many people are
clicking on these various links
in the Firebase console.  We get
different behavior based on the
plaque        platform that
people are using.  But we also
have now a much better
internship because now we're
doing what our users
experience, because
they're using the Web page that
takes them to the app.  Web
page             .
Where he is
Recipe blank her
wring her is not
Recipe Wrangler is not a real
app.  I'll ask rag     rag
Ragabond to cuj        to come
back up.
>> . App People
.
(Applause)
>> One of the big uses is to
take the app installed, make
sure the context is propagated.
We'll see how some apps are
doing this.  This is a Korean
app for couples.  You can see
there is something on the
anniversary, and the developer
wants this particular shared
item to be opened in the app.
This app does not actually have
a website.  They only have an
app.  You have to always take
them to an app installed if they
want to see it.
That particular link is
actually a dynamic link.  If the
app is not installed, it takes
them to the app install, and
when opens for the first time it
shows the first item.  In this
case it was a photograph, also
could be used for a background.
links are being set     used to
set up a paired use in your app
and also group relationships.
One person in the group or the
pair has the app, and you want
to onboard the others in that
group, dynamic links are great
to be used for invites.  The
first person can invite the
others and all the others get
personalized warm welcomes to
invite them into the app.
This is a second use case where
before dynamic links this
particular flow starts off with
an e-mail saying, hey, they can
check this out in the
app, and the user goes through
the install process.  The app
doesn't know it came for this
particular content
, so it takes it through the
default onboarding screen, and
you can go back and find the
search option in the app and
search for the content.  They
might have forgot what it was,
go back to the e-mail, get the
content and search for it.  It
takes them more than a dozen
clicks to actually get to their
content.
With dynamic links this makes it
very, very nice ask clean
nice and clean.  The
app opener knows what the
content is for and it goes down.
So what is the benefit of
doing something like this?  So
one of our partners actually has
been using this in exactly the
scenario.  What they found is
that dynamic links increase
their attention up to four weeks
by 92% for users who came in
from these links.  This has a
big impact on attention.
>> .
>> attention.
Google maps    Maps.  You can
use dynamic links to effectively
convert app users if you think
the app can provide them with a
better experience.  Here once
the user has searched for some
content, something they actually
care about, you can give them
the option.  In this case to
e-mail it to yourself and to
this e-mail comes, e-mail it or
text to to themselves and e-mail
the to
hemselves
and e-mail the message.  When
they click on it, if the app is
present, directly opens the app,
; not present, it goes through
the install flow.  When they
come onto the site, they have
the content right there.  And if
the link or the message is
opened on a platform where there
is no app for the service,
that's totally fine, because you
can configure the link to be
opened in that case, too
.
This is -- this use case
converts mobile web users.  They
are doing a promotion with a
very unique marketing campaign
where you can actually scan a
particular logo on coke bottles
and that will leave       lead
you to a very unique lip sync
experience, where you can share
it on social media and here you
can share it on Facebook.  So
when somebody actually clicks on
their friend's shared lip sync
video, it takes you to a mobile
Web page where
a mobile web
page.  This is a way to convert
the user to an app user.  It is
a call to action that says make
your own lip sync video and
share it on social media.
Here if you did not have dynamic
links, they would have to have
two buttons here.  One that says
if you have the app, click here
.  If you don't           you
don't have it, download it and
hopefully you can figure out in
the app how you can come back to
this place; right?  So dynamic
links is perfect here.  It's one
button that works in both cases
, and in both cases leads you to
the right place.
onboarding users and desktop to
app.  One of the common cases is
sharing.  Let's see how this
can be used for sharing.  So
going back to Todd's  's exactly
, it turns out our food blogger
isn't       isn't the only
ger is the only
one that wants to share recipes.
Our users want to share recipe
s.  In Recipe Wrangler for each
recipe,al   allow them to make a
dynamic links for each recipe
that they can now post and share
on social media, by e-mail.  So
everybody can pass this around.
As the piece gets passed
around, Recipe Wrangler, our
food app, gets more users.
That's great.  And so since they
use dynamic links, they use all
the benefits we talked about.
It works in app installed cases,
in Android and IOS, all the
scenarios.  All they have to do
is add some boilerplate code.
Just create the deep link and
find the e-mail contact and then
find the SMS contact.  Maybe if
you want to be really good,
have a recommendation engine
that can suggest who you should
share this with, because you may
not want to scroll through 200
people in the contact list to
find the people they want to
share it with.  And then have a
pretty e-mail that's pre
formatted that they can modify
so that they can customize it.
And then ideally, send the
e-mails from the app itself
without having to go into an
e-mail client.
So it does take a little bit of
work, but dynamic links are
great in this kind of flow.  If
only this could be a little
easier, that would be really
great, but this shows your
dynamic links can be used.
So thank you very much for
coming --
>> No, wait, wait, wait. We're
not done yet.  We got one more
feature.
>> We're not?
>> Todd ODD: My gosh,
don't       don't end yet.  You
see, we recognize that the whole
process of kind of creating all
these links and sending them
off through e-mail and SMS is
kind of valuable, also kind of a
pain to do       to do.  And so
we decided to standardize the
process for you in my nice
little package.  You're still
more than welcome to go ahead
and generate your own dynamic
links and serve them however you
want.  You can still do that,
but for SMS and e-mail, which
tends to be two of the most
common situations, we have a
solution that you can use right
away.
So generally this is how it
would work:  On IOS you're
basically going to create an
invite builder and you'll give
it a bunch of parameters that
sorts       sort of changes its
behavior.  What the deep link
info is going to be for the
people that receive this invite.
That's the important one, as
well as maybe what you want the
default outbound message to be
for that user.  If you want to
customize the call to action
button or that kind of thing,
once do you that, you'll open up
the dialogue and it will appear
as sort of a view controller
right on top of your current
app.
Ah Android, almost
.
On Android, you'll create an
intent, set all the various
parameters around what you want
the fault       default message
to be, the deep link info to be
and so on, and you'll launch it
to get the UI.  What you get on
IOS is something that looks a
little like this.  A few notes
about this invite dialogue,
you'll note we are missing
we are mixing in SMS
and e-mail.  That's good.  It
turns out a lot of users, they
only have either the e-mail
address or the phone number
phone number of
their recipients; right?  They
don't       don't have both and
having them in one convenient
location is awfully nice.  Also,
you'll notice that we have some
suggestions from Google folks
or from Google based on folks we
think you might want to talk to
based on sort of who we think
your best friends are, or
who   at least who you want to
communicate with.  And so that
can be             that can be
very useful if your best friends
happen to be, you know, William
and Zina, and you don't
you don't want to scroll
through three00         three00
different contacts
through 300 contacts to get to
those people.
What your recipients will see is
a default message that looks
something like this.  You'll
notice the subject line is the
customized user message that
your user has sent to people.
And then the actual content of
the e-mail is what we have
automatically grabbed from the
App Store or the Play Store for
you.  So you kind of can see the
description, which is directly
from the App Store and the
screen shots and so on.
This is pretty good for
delivering a nice looking e-mail
with eight lines of code, but
if you do want to do a little
more and have a little more
control on what this invitation
looks like, you can add in an
e-mail content parameter.  And
so this is a parameter where you
would generate a whole bunch of
HTML or supply in a whole bunch
of HTML and that would control
what the e-mail invitation would
look like to those recipients.
It not only let's you design
your invitation exactly the way
you would like, but also because
it's happening right there in
your app.  You can
.  You can customize
that invitation right as you're
sending it, uke have custom
it, you can
have custom information that
the user would share.
This is what they did.  If you
want to share a recipe instead
of the e-mail containing some
generic e-mail about the app,
they said well, gosh we have all
this recipe info right here,
let's put that into the e-mail.
So what you get is a little bit
more about the recipe.  You get
to see the picture of the
chocolate peppermint cookies,
which look delicious, because
maybe because it's
lunchtime, and a little bit of a
snippet of the recipe to get
you interested.  Then you're a
little more inspired to click on
the link that says, well, yes,
I would like to install that app
.
Oh, man, these guys really have
a good recipe app already.
Looks like it's back to the
drawing board for John and Mary.
Oh, that's good.  They have a
backup plan.
So the process for receiving
invites, it's almost the same as
for receiving a deep link.  On
IOS, instead of passing the URL
you get into the dynamic links
library, you pass it to the
Firebase dynamic links
it to Firebase Inbox library.
On Android you, you don't
Android,
you don't           you don't
need to do anything.  The code
is exactly the same for incoming
Firebase invites       Invites.
Now let's move to the one bit of
bummer news.  So on Android,
you don't           you don't
need to be signed in at all
to send or receive an invite.
Anybody is free to send any
invitations they want.  Anybody
is free to accept any invitation
s and that's all great.
On IOS, you also don't
don't need to be signed in to
receive an invite.  You get an
invite coming in, go ahead, and
you can kind of click on that in
your e-mail and take you to
your app and so on.
So maybe you can see where we're
going here.  You do, however,
have to be signed in with Google
to send invitations on IOS.
Now, maybe for some of you
that's not a problem, your app
already uses sign-in and Google
is one of your preferred sign-in
providers and you're thinking
this is gien, most of
this is fine.
Maybe your app doesn't have sign
-in at all or maybe you're not
adding Google sign-     Sign-in
to your app.  Well, okay.
That's not a big deal.  I'll put
.  Put      .  I'll
put the Firebase in my app.  I
can still get some viral effects
from getting all the invites.
Here is the problem with that.
Android users and IOS users
sometimes still talk to each
other.  Frequently they're often
friends
.  And so the problem is that
your Android users are going to
send these invitations not only
to other Android users, but also
IOS users as well.  The IOS
users will click on the
invitation.  They will go
through the process of install
your app, but then if you
haven't implemented any kind of
fair base logic
kind of Firebase logic
on the app, it will give your
users the generic home screen
instead of the great recipe your
users are trying to share.
They'll be sad and confused.
What I recommend is at the very
least, if you're adding Firebase
d invites on Android, make sure
that you add the ability to
receive invites on IOS.  Like
you saw, the code is very nearly
identical to the deep link
parsing we did earlier.  This
will make sure that      that
your Android users can still
send invites to whoever they
want and they will get accepted.
Your IOS users won't be
confused.  Again, totally up to
you whether you want to add in
sending invitations on IOS.
There you go, that is fair basin
invites       Invites
, that is
Firebase invites       Invites
in a nutshell.
>> Thank you, Todd. Let's recap
.  In this talk we covered
dynamic links.  Now you know how
to use them to make great
marketing URLs for your app and
product.  We also looked at
invites       Invites, an out of
the box invite flow for very
effective sharing on invites on
SMS and e-mail.    information,
please head over to your Sandbox
for support.  We have a
playground for you to create
dynamic links, that's at FDL
-links.  And you can go ahead
and create some dynamic links
and play with them and try all
the parameters out.
This is all the remaining talk
going on.  So we'll be around
here after this talk and happy
to answer any questions off the
stage.
Thank you.
(Applause)
11:00 P   a.m.
1:00 p.m. PT
AN23
a
.
Test
>> Hi,
everyone.
>> Thank
you.  Thanks for coming.  My
name is Dan
Aminzade a software engineer at
Google and dedicate ed tri
triathlete.  On a good week I
bike 50 miles and write 3,000
lines of code.  Maybe it's no
surprise I work on the Google
Fit for Android Wear and it
makes good use of the Google
Fit APIs we'll be showing you
today.
>> MUZ MUSTOF: I enjoy
weightlifting, yoga, and
occasionally experiments with
different diets.  Today we're
going to talk about building
rich experiences with the
Google Fit platform and Android
Wear.  I'll start out by
talking about why we create ed
the Fit platform, what problem
problems we set out to solve,
and then Dan will go over the
APIs and data types.ext we'll
loo at some specific examples of
what you
can build with a Fit platform,
first basic fitness tracking
and then a more advance ed
realtime fitness use case.
Finally we'll finish up
with some really cool demos
coming soon. start out by
introducing the Fit platform.
We'll explain why we create ed
Fit, what problems we set out
solve, and why we believe fit
ness is such a great use
case for wearables. the Google
Fit platform existed, life for a
fitness application developer
was not easy.  It was
integration hell.  First issue
was that of siloed data.  It
uses health and fitness data is
siloed across multiple apps
and fitness devices. there was
no easy access and storage of
sensor data.  No easy way for
developers to read, interpret
health and fitness-relate ed
devices, centered on compact
such as Android Wear devices.
The third problem was
poor interoperate anlt
interoperability.
There
was no standard way to operate.
So without the standard
ecosystem, app developers had
to have their own platform
and API.  Some are poorly
implemented, leading to user
frustration. the Google Fit
platform we solve ed that
problem
with giving apps one single
APIs to access, record, and
store phone data, wearable data
, and other app data. by using
my phone or my wear devices, my
fitness
hub, I can connect my fitness
wearable to my favorite
nutrition app and my sleep
tracking app to my favorite
meditation app.e don't just
consolidate data though.  With
user
consent we provide low-level
sensor recording and perform
hard computations for things
like distance and calories.
Whether it's resting heart rate
from heart rate timestamps,
distances fuse ed from your
height, steps and GPS, or
calorie
calories from heart rate.
The Fit platform makes it
easy ier for health and fit
fitness application developers.
And fitness and wearables
truly go and in hand.  This is
for a few reasons.  First,
the sensors.  Your app can get
access to all of these ways
of measure ing fitness
activity ies.  Many watches have
a GPS
sensor, a heart rate monitor,
and potentially even a
barometer.nd because the watch
is worn on the wrist it, allows
us to detect activity ies we
couldn't do with the phone being
that's the first reason, sensor
sensors., you can leave the
phone.  I love my nexus 6P
but running with a device is a
bit cumbersome.  I have to
rely on infrequent audio keys
to find out my current pace
because I can't see the scene
when it's in an armband or in
my pocket.hird is faster input.
When you're on the go with,
you can have quick interactions
with a watch to control
music or activity recording
that would take much longer if
you had to rely on pulling out
your phone and opening up
the right app.
Now, let's talk about
what the Google fifth       Fit
platform
provides that enables you to
build rich experiences in line
of what we just discussed.,
let's talk about the Google Fit
app on both
phone and Android Wear.  If
you're not familiar with the
app, you see that it tracks
walking, running, and bike ing
using the Google Fit platform's
APIs that detect activity,
are associate ed step, calorie,
and disstance
distances.
The app also shows data
from connected third party
devices and apps such as
exercise sessions, weights,
heart
rate, nutrition data, and
sleep.
Our platform
automatically synchronize ing
between your
Android phone, your Android
Wear, and the web.  The Fit
platform exists in all three of
these.  You can write in about
REST APIs on the web or disk on
the phone or SDK
anywhere.  It handles merge ing
and reduplication of this
data intelligently and we even
support Takeout information
if the user wants to export
their data.  So now that you've
gotten
a overview of the Google fifth
platform and why it
Fit platform
let me tell you about
the different API it is
provides.  Basically it breaks
down
into four paips       APIs.
For there is the sensor am API
from
Android devices and wearable
sensors.  Things like heart
rate.  Then there is a
RecordingApi, that does
automatic
mate ed storage
mate ed store using
subscriptions, Google Fit will
store it
in the background and have a
prescription for you.
Next there is the history
API that gives you access
to the fitness history and lets
you perform bulk operations
like reading and inserting
data.  Then there is the
session
sessions API, that's a metadata
layer on top of raw fitness
date
data that let you store whole
fitness activity ies, so a
session is a time interval in
which the user is doing a
bike ride or run or weight
lifting session.s far as what
you can record, we support
really all
the standard data types for
diet, nutrition, body, activity
activity, sleep.  We're also
adding this new hydration data
type.  I think this is a pretty
exhaustive list of fitness
metrics but if there is one
that's not in here that you
would like to log in your app,
you should let us know.o let's
start by talking just about
basic fitness
tracking.  You can't measure
what you don't track, so track
really I think the first step
toward motivate ing people
toward better fitness.  I
started
tracking my workouts 10 years
ago in 2006 when I was
training for my first marathon.
I bought my first wrist-
wrist-mounted GPS.  It was the
uncomfortable thing like the
siefs a chinchila on my list.
It did what you it could.
Back then there weren't any
nice portals or fitness
platforms.  I built this
website with Google maps API 1.0
there.  There is something
thrilling from a data geek like
me to come back from a work
workout and analyze my stats on
pace and heart rate and
elevation, and I could really
track my progress from week
to week and workout to workout.
So these days, obviously
there are much are mo
elegant and full-feature ed
alternatives where I can analyze
friends and track my
progress toward fitness goals.
And also I don't have to
wear a big giant ugly thing on
my wrist, I can wear this
really,  -- you know, these
beautiful timepieces from Tag
Heuer or Michael Kors and still
track throughout the day
with the watchface.  This is my
favorite watchface here.
The Fit Cat (Laughing) yeah.
(Applause).
It try ies
to encourage you to be more acti
ve.  So
basically if you haven't seen
this before the more active
the more steps you take the
more cute he becomes.  I love
that he's wearing the I/O badge
and wearing a Android Wear
as well.  The more steps you
take, the more active the cat
becomes.  Trying to build will
something like this on your
own is not easy.  There is a
lot of stuff you would have to
do it on your own.  You would
have to build a data stare to
track step, turn on permissions
, record step counts in a
way that won't kill the watch
battery, if you get that part
working, then when the user
first installs your watchface,
it will record zero, it will
show zero because you haven't
been recording yet.
And then there is all
these edge cases like the user
takes off the watch and goes
for a walk with the phone in
their pocket.  Then you have to
write the logic to merge in
that data.  Even if approximate
you solve these problems,
the step count is probably not
going to be consistent with
other watchfaces in other apps.
So fortunately we solve ed
all these problems for you with
the Google Fit platform.
We store steps in the
background in a nice low-power
battery friendly way and
they're ready to be read any
time
you like and you get consistent
step counts on Android Wear
with one method call.  Let me
show you how to do that. when
you want to connect to the
Google Fit
platform, you create a
GoogleApiClient.  Normally you
create an authenticate ed one
where you specify the account
you want to read data for.  So
here is how I build the
client.  I say I'm interested
in reading fitness history
data, so I add the Fitness
History API.  I add scopes to
the particular types of data I
want to read, so in this
case activity type, location,
and body sensor data like
heart rate.
And then next I add in a
count.  This is the count I
want to read the data from,
then my callbacks now I have
this authenticate ed client I
can use to make query ies to the
fitness platform.ut wait you're
saying, Android Wear watches
don't
have accounts.  This is true.
Android Wear 2.0 will
actually add account support,
but for now we don't have
accounts on watches.
Fortunately there is a solution.
Now
Now, you could sync account
information from the phone, but
that would require your watchf
ace to have a companion phone
app which is a lot more
complicate ed.  Here is a easy
way to
do it without a phone app.  You
can create a no account
client.  You create a
GoogleApiClient as before, we
have
the history API, then set
default account.  Don't specify
a
account.  Finish building.
Then we have a no account we
can still use to inquiry step
accounts and you do that with
the read daily totals method.
You call the history API
read daily total method, and
this is basically going to
give you a simple way to get
step counts for watchface
that's going to be consistent
with other apps in other
watchfaces.  You can set a call
back so when the result
returns you can process it.  So
here in the on-result I'm ng
out the step count, putting it
into a steps
total vary iable, and there you
go, it's a pretty simple way
to track steps with your
watchface.
And it's not just steps
that you can am, that you can
get from the Google Fit
platform, right.  Can you read
and
right other data like calories
consume ed.  Here is an
example of how the Lifesum app
displays that data.  Here
I'm looking at the amount of
calories I have left in the
budget for the day rnlings 91
like 911 I could eat
two avocados and
drink two classes of wine
tonight.  Android Wear 2.0 is
going to have a new way to show
data.  Maybe you've seen
some of this early ier in the
keynote.  But basically on the
right there is a watchface with
three complications and it
lets you select which
complications you want and any
app
can provide date a for the
complications.
Here is an example where
life is export
Lifesum is exporting data on
the calories burns to the
switch on the right can display
in one of those three user
configurable slots.  If you want
more information on building
those in had Android Wear 2.0.
I highly recommend you check
out the talk, a dedicate ed talk
>> MUZ MUSTOF: Another
chal ebbing
challenge that fitness
developers face is how to
perform difficult computations.
For example, to derive distance
traveled from multiple
sensor inputs, the users height
, stride length, GPS data,
activity type, active time, and
step counts all have to be
fuse ed into together.
Potentially across multiple
sensor
inputs.
The fifth platform makes
this easy for third party
developers through its advance
ed transformations for both
distance and calories.  The
basis app takes advantage of
this.  Instead of computing
distance themselves, they write
in steps and activity data into
the Google Fit platform and
read back our compute ed values
for distance.
>> DAN AMINZADE: Cool,
so let's take a look at mow
we might do
how
we might do this with the
Google Fit platform.  There is
two ways to write data to the
platform.  Can you use the
RecordingApi to do live
recording or the history API to
insert history.  Of let's start
by looking at live record
recording.  All we have to do
to start live record
something subscribe to the data
type we care about.  So
here I'm calling subscribe, and
saying I'm interested in
activity samples or activity t
ypes. then I actually at that
point, I'm essentially
done.  Google Fit will start
store ing the data I care about
in the background, so I don't
need my own database or back-
back-end to store it.  There is
no listener needed here.
Basically the Google Fit
platform is going to sync data
and
sync to Cloud in the
background.  When I want it
later can
I read it with the history API.
So once I subscribe, I'm
done.  All I really need to do
is check the status code in
the result and that's to make
sure the subscription
succeeded.
Let's look at another way
to get data into the fit
fitness history.  Suppose I got
the data from an external
source like another device.
Say they wanted to write in
steps they got from another
device.  So first you create
this data source object, you
specify the type of data you
want to write.  I'm saying I
want to write raw step count
data.  Then you create a
DataSet from the data source and
add one or more data points to
the set each has a start and
end time.  Here I'm adding 950
steps with a start and end
time.  And then finally you
just call insert data to put
the data into the fitness
history.  That's about it.  All
you really have to do after
that is verify that the
operation succeeded before you
start querying the data with
the history API.  One nice
thing is the fifth platform will
put in a invalid time range
or unrealistically high calorie
born or cadence or
something like that, I'll get
an error back on the client
instead of the user fitness
history getting all messed up.
here is how this actually looks
in the Basis app.
They put in step, then you can
see they're able to derive
from that or through the Google
Fit platform they get this
accurate distance traveled.
>> MUZ MUSTOF: We've
been working hard over the
past year to improve the
quality of these transformations
.
The first area with which we've
improve ed them is in
relation to distance.  Distance
compute ed from steps now is
a bit improve ed with stride
length calibration from actively
tracked walks and runs to
improve the quality of passively
for calories you will soon by
leverage ing
gender, age, and heart rate as
part of the computations to
improve the accuracy.ly, for
merge ing, previously leave ing
your phone
at your desk and going for your
walk with your Android Wear
device would result in your
step counts dipping back down
and then rubberbanding back up.
That will no longer be the
case through bidirectional
syncing.  We've also made merge
merging of GPS data better with
by prioritize ing the highest
fidelity GPS sources.
Finally, with regards to
activity, this is our most
complex task, to infer the
activity being performed by
analyzing multiple sensor
inputting in realtime.  It's
really important, as use ers
get frustrate ed when their
fit
fitness data has false positive
and false negative activity
get their proper calories and
step counts as a result.
Fortunately, Google is good and
trusted at collecting and
understanding complex data
through our advance ed machine-
learning capability ies.  We've
added dynamic sample ing of
sensor inputs to improve
quality,
and have made improvements to
our algorithms by fuse ing step
user corrections together.he
result of this hard work, over
the past year, is
a reduction in our bike ing
precision error rates from 11%
error in early 2015 down to 4%
error as of now.  And these
changes will be rolling out now
.inally, we've added stride
length calibration to the
fifth platform which we hope
Fit platform which we hope will
benefit nonGPS Android Wear
devices.  Now if a user goes
running, initially with their
phone and watch which has --
the phone which has GPS and
the watch which doesn't, the
two will calibrate together by
-- and generate a stride model,
and then they'll get
accurate distance and pace e
stimates running without their
phone, just with their nonGPS
Android Wear device.
Now that we've looked at
some basic fitness tracking
examples, I want to talk about
owsh push this
our push this year into real
realtime fitness tracking.  Why
is realtime so important
when building a motivate ing
fitness experience?
Well, when I look at
fitness         fitness apps out
there and I
look at a lot out there, I see
they adopt this framework.
They start with a imoal of the
goal of the user.
For example, I'd like
to lose 10 pounds, I'd like to
sleep better, or I'd like to
finish a half marathon.  They
recognize that in order to
accomplish this goal, they need
to encourage a pattern of
motivate ing actions so that
the user achieves the result
that they desire.  Let's drill
into the motivate ing actions.
are three pillars of wellness,
exercise,
nutrition, and recovery.
Recovery we mean to mean sleep
and medication
meditation.  These pillars
pillars do not operate i
ndependently
independently, and behavior in
one needs to be balance ed
against the other.  By getting
a holistic view of what's
going on in each of these areas
, injure app can more
intelligently and insightfully
present suggestions and
knowledge based on a change ing
fitness context in realtime.
example, a sleep app might
observe that you sleep
better when you exercise..or
when you eat less sugar in the
evening.  An exercise app may
suggest exercise based on
your logged nutrition data so
that you meet your weightloss
goals., that in all of these
cases, timely iness is
important.  The best time to
coach and motivate a user is
immediately in response to an
action that they have taken
in relation to their fitness.
So good apps have an in-b
uilt awareness of the users
overall fitness context.  One
of our partners Lifesum makes
heavy use of these principles
through their application and
they integrate deeply with the
fifth platform API
Fit platform APIs and as a
result they see double
retention rates for users
connected
to fifth       Fit versus users
not connected to Fit. are the
APIs we've added to let you
respond in
realtime to a change ing
fitness context for your user.
First, it's realtime data
update notifications had.  It
allows you to be notified for
certain data-types in the fit
fitness store when they change.
The second is realtime
session notifications.  It's
actually been in the Fit
platform for a while, but we'd
like to talk about it today.
It allows you to be notified
that the user has started or
finished a workout tracked in
a third party application.
Finally realtime activity
recognition.  Coming soon
to Android Wear devices to
detect the unset activity to
launch into your activity acti
ve tracking experience. first
API, realtime data update note
of courses.
This allows us to build the
following experience.  Say I
had an am impromptu pizza and I
exceeded my calorie intake
goal for the day.  I get a
notification from the weight
scale app telling me exercise
is needed to keep you on
track to meet your weight loss
goal.
>> DAN AMINZADE: I do
admit I have a weakness for
that looked pretty delicious,
let's see how we
could build something like that
example that Muz just
describe ed.  We want to
describe to updates     dates.
We create a
PendingIntent.  This is
typically a PendingIntent for an
call into your app whenever
an update to one of these data
types occurs.
What you then do is
create a Data Update Listener
Registration Request, which is
a lot
of -- it is a pretty
dedescriptive name, and we're
going to pass in the type of
data that we'd like to describe
to updates for, so in this
case nutrition, we're
interested in meals being logg
ed.
Then we pass in the
PendingIntent we create ed.
Then finally
we call this registered data
update             data update
listener method, and we
pass in the client and request.
Then we get a update with
the next logged meal.  Of
course, you can register for
up   to all different kinds of
data types
.  For example,
if I want to be notified the
user steps on the scale and
logs a new weight, I can do
that with type weight.  And
here are actually all of the
data types that support real
realtime update, pretty much
that anything that isn't up
update ed super frequently.
second API, realtime session
up
update notifications allows,
for example, a nutrition app
to be notified that the user
just finished a workout
session.  So say you just
finished a weight lifting
session
session, your nutrition app can
tell you, it's time to get
a high-protein meal in to
maximize muscle growth.  Or say
a
hydration app, it can suggest
rehydrate ing immediately after
finishing a 21 minute run
outdoors. been so hot here, I
think we
can all use hydration reminder,
even when we haven't been
running, just walking around
outside.  So let's build that
one.  Similar API to the one we
just looked at with the
history API.  But here we're
going to use the sessions API
because we're interestedded in
registering for updates when
a session starts or ends.  So
again we create a
PendingIntent that we'd like to
fire when a new session
begins or ends.  And then we
call this register for session
sessions method in the sessions
API, and now whenever the
user starts or ends a workout,
the PendingIntent will fire
and intent will be delivered to
our app.  If you want to
get more information on that
session, you can actually
extract it from out of the
intent, so here I'm pulling out
the start and end time, and
then also the type of workout
so whether it was a run or bike
ride or weight lifting
session, then I can put that
into the notification like the
one that Muz just showed.ne
excite ing new development
coming to the Google Fit
platform this year is we're
going to allow your app to
register not only for explicit
sessions that the user
initiate, but also for implicit
sessions.  These are ones
that are automatically detected
by our platform.
So what it means is that
your app can respond in real
realtime to a user's fitness
activity.  If I just lace up
my shoes and start running, my
favorite run tracking app
can just start up automatically
on my watch.  So I'm going
to try to show you a demo of
how that works.  I'm not
really properly dressed for
running, but I'm going to do a
little run around here.  Okay.
I just felt my wrist vibe
brait which means Strava should
have started on the watch,
let's go over here and take a
look.  There we go.  You see
that Strava is now recording my
run.
(Applause).
And I will
post that on Strava later, so I
hope you me some kudos.  Here
you go.
>> MUZ MUSTOF: Awesome.
So we got a couple of
really -- three actually really
excite ing new features
coming on Android Wear toward
the end of the year.  We've
added a Bhat API          beat
to beat API in Android M.  It
computes heart
rate vary iability ies which is
a proxy for stress levels for
the user.
Second, we're adding a
ProfileApi, this allows you to
easily onboard your new users
by reading age, gender,
heights, and weights from the
fifth platform.  Finally
Fit
platform.  Always goals,
allowing you to show the
progress against that step goal
and active time, distance and
calorie goals as well from
Google Fit.here is another
excite ing feature that some of
you
guys might have seen at the
sandbox already.  Of when I go
to the gym, I notice that a lot
of people are still using
an old-school pen and paper to
log their exercise, their
rep, their weights.  It seems a
bit crazy in 2016.  Well,
Google Fit and Android Wear did
count reps for you for
three specific exercises,
push-ups, sit-ups and squats but
only if you told the app in
advance what you were doing.
This is still somewhat
limited and cumbersome.  Now
we've got something better.  So
I'm going to show you a
demo.
>> DAN AMINZADE: Oh,
come on.  Give me a break
(Laughing).kay.  So I'm going
to the Google
Fit strength training section.
And I haven't told it the
exercise I'm about to do.
>> DAN AMINZADE: Come
on.
(Applause).
He's
working hard for you guys.
>> MUZ MUSTOF: As you
can see it detected bicep
curls with 100% and counted the
reps.  It was 15 pounds, so
I'll just log that.
Let's do another
exercise, one which involves the
leg
legs.  Note that I can take
some time just kind of setting
up.good form.not (Laughing).
You can see it
got dead lift.
If a rep is
missed or an exercise isn't
correct for
whatever reason, we will learn
from that mistake and become
trained to the user's exercise
motion.  We aim to
seamlessly track a whole
workout with minimal user input.
We're planning an API towards
the end of this year and
we're looking for partners.
>> DAN AMINZADE: All
right.  That's our overview of
the Google Fit platform.
Before we wrap up, we just want
to thank all of our part ners
already using the Google Fit
platform for inspire and lead
people around the world to
lead more healthy and active
lifestyles.  At the end of the
day this talk isn't really
about PendingIntent and broad
extended          extending
life  ves and so we hope
you'll be able to get out there
and build the next
generation of fitness
experiences on Android.  Thanks
so
much for your time and
attention.  Feel free to contact
us
with any questions.  Thank you.
Designing & Developing for the
Daydream Controller.
(  )
>> YOU GOOD?
>> BASHEER TOME: YES.
YES.  WELCOME TO OUR SESSION.
IF YOU'RE HERE TO LEARN ABOUT
THE DAY AGREEMENT CONTROLLER AND
HOW TO DESIGN AND LEARN HOW TO
DEVELOP IT, YOU'RE IN THE RIGHT
PLACE.  WHAT WE'LL DO THIS
SESSION IN THREE MAIN CHAPTERS,
HOW, WHY, WHAT.  WE'LL DIVE
BRIEFLY IN THE DESIGN OF THE
CONTROLLER ITSELF, WALK THROUGH
THE TECHNICAL CONCEPTS ON HOW TO
IMPLEMENT THE CONTROLLER
SUPPORT UNITED NATIONSTY IN
IN UNITY C++ AND
WE'LL SHOW WHAT THIS INPUT
DIVIDE, WHAT IT CAN REALLY DO
FROM SCHELL
GAMES.
This is going to be great for so
meanings, VV, and has a ton of
-- has so much potential.
That's what makes it a
compelling experience to so many
people.  For many people, the
applications you're building
right now, they're going to be
some of the first experiences in
VR.  The more we thought about
that, the more we realized that
we needed to build a better,
more mammer
immersive way to be
involved in VR.  You wouldn't
have to keep a hand up like they
do in some stackable
experiences
of Cardboard.  We made this
Daydream Controller.  This
doesn't float in the air like it
does on this slide.  It is
something to hold in your hand
that we have created for our new
Daydream Controller platform to
help people.  Enabling you to
explore and manipulate things
naturally by letting you
directly point at and click on
objects, hold a tool in the
virtual world and navigate
venues.
We spent a lot of time and
energy in ord to create
something that is accessible and
simple enough for new users and
people of all kinds of
interests and enables everyone
to express themselves
creatively, directly, precisely,
I went accurately and doesn't
force them to lug around
something huge.  The goal was a
powerful, simple tool that fits
right in your pocket.  Let's
start from the top.
The Daydream Controller has a
curved, clicking touch pad
allowing people to make fine
grain manipulations and request
I can swipes for scrolling
allowing them to make click
selections without lifting the
thumb.  How does that work?  If
you look at the side of the
controller we have achieved this
by embedding a tack till
clickable switch directly by the
touch pad allowing the top
housing to flex when you apply
pressure with your finger.
There's something that is not
too unfamiliar for laptop touch
top users.
Below the touch pad, there are
two buttons, the home and app.
The home button  , it is
reserved entirely for this
system, pressing it takes people
immediately back to the home
world while holding it down for
a little bit longer let's them
reorient their view.
The app button, as you can
guess, has functional till
reserved for app developers.
For example, you can use it to
enable switching from a hammer
to a saw.  More often than not,
to open up a menu.  In some
cases, undoing a failed Pancake
flip.
Since your phone is inside of
the viewer and audio is an
important part of the VR we have
put hardware volume buttons
directly in your hand to make it
so that people can reach them
conveniently and quickly.
However, the most important and
foundational aspect of the
controller is the ability to
directly point in 3D space
around you.  We use a highly
calibrated access IMU combining
and infusing data from      to
output in absolute rotation
value in VR space.
This means that instead of
relying entirely on a touch pad
to scroll through lists locked
to the view port or turning your
head in every direction to
click on something, up point
directly at it instead with your
hand and click.   Because it is
on a chip you can do that
anywhere around you,   be it
straight ahead, right, Ben
behind you.  All of that the
without having to set up an
extra camera or tracking system.
and in hardware and software, we
have been developing both in
parallel as a team together.
Here is one of our happy early
prototypes that we have used in
development because of its
similarity and size we lovingly
call it the garage door opener.
Is various teams around the
world have been using these to
test and prototype software and
hardware stack.  As we got
deeper into the project we
realized we couldn't mail one of
these to everyone out there and
we with would love for both
everyone here in person as well
as other developers to tin
corporate this input into your
development process while
creating the new VR apps.  Br
uno, we found a better way, it
is in your pocket.  Most mobile
phones today contain all of the
hardware you need to replicate
the controller minus the click.
We created an app which you'll
be able to download called the
controller immolator and
although the orientation sensors
may not be as precise sore
calibrated as in the final
hardware spec it should be a
great alternative to get off the
are prototyping fast.
With a second phone you'll be
able to start up the app
creating a hot spot and connects
to the viewer to broadcast
input in realtime.  That said,
because we're working in a VR
world that's only tracked by a
rotation, you are essentially
blindfolded while in there and
you're holding a phone that is
way bigger than the hardware
controller spec.  We have
created a sticker overlay to
guide your fingers.  The
capacity comes you have to
cleanly and still gives you
right amount of tactile feedback
to find the real size life
sized buttons on screen.  We
have the scissors and papers and
lasers files and a link to
other   material, all of that is
going to be in the download
itself and online under the
developer site.  I have a batch
of them premade with
me.   After this talk, I'll sit
outside of the tent if you want
to grab one, ask questions.
Bruno will show you how to
implement the SDK and how to
enable up to use both this
immolator and the final hardware
in your apps and switching
between
the two should actually be
seamless and require almost no
coaching.
Before I go, I wanted to leave
you with a pretty simple
question, with this controller
we're excited about the
possibilities you'll come up
with.  You could hold a tennis
racket, a whisk, frisbee,
steering wheel, so much more in
your pocket.
What do you make in VR?
Thanks.
In my section of the talk we're
going to speak a lot about goad.
What
is it?  From the left side you
have the user, and say on the
right side you have some
abstract concept, happiness, the
only thing that is standing
between those two is the code
that we write.  That's why code
is so important.  Before we talk
about code, let's go briefly
into the things you will need to
write code for the controller.
If you have the controller on
one side and you have the phone
on the other, how do these two
things communicate.  Anyone have
a guess?  Blue tooth, a   great
guess.
It is Bluetooth low energy, the
phone talks to the controller
and the app is on the phone with
the VR energy.   If you're not
exactly the type of developer
that wakes up every morning
thinking yeah, let's write some
low level blue tooth code, don't
worry, you won't have to.  You
actually because of the Google
VR services is a layer that
talks blue tooth directly to the
controller so your app doesn't
have to.  Instead your app
interacts directly with the
Google VRSDK and that does the
hard work of can communicating
with the Google services and
ultimately to the controller.
available later only in the
year.  If you want to -- if you
want to start developing right
now you can.  All you have to do
is assemble your own kit.  Your
dev kits has a viewer, you also
need an XX6P as the phone and
you need to install the Android
developer on that phone.
Instead of a real controller,
use a secondary phone as a
controller immolator.  You need
one of these and two phones.
From the perspective of
development, not much changes,
you may worry do I have to write
code especially for the
immolator and change everything?
No.  The goal of VR services
deals with the code that
actually speaks to the
controller so in terms of SDK,
same thing, you don't have to
worry if you're using the
immolator or controller.  .
SDK comes in several flavors,
you can go to
developerses/VR to start
developing today.  You don't
have
to wait for the real
controller.
The features, they're common
regardless of what you use,
there are five main features,
orientation, gyroscope, , a
touch pad, several buttons.
Let's go in details on each.
Orientation, perhaps the most
intuitive one.  Other
Orientation, where is the
controller pointing in 3D space.
It is a controller not only
because this, it is a cool word
but it means 3 of freedom.
Which 3 of freedom are those?
That is the YA, where you point
the controller, the pitch, also
the elevation and the roll,
which is also called twist or
bang.  Those three angles, the
3D freedom of the controller.
This is an interesting
mathematical entity.  In most
cases, if you're using a math
library or argyle           or a
game engine you can treat them
as a black box or blue box.
They encode the rotation that
you can apply to a vector.  If
you want to look inside of a
vector, it is not that hard.  It
has a vector component, made up
of X, Y, Z, it has a scaler
component and a fifth component,
anyone know what that fifth
component is?  No.  It is magic.
That's the only way I can
believe in how they work p.
That's what I thought in the
beginning.    as I studied them
I realized that the scientific
truth is that they're 60% magic,
the rest, it is not.  We
represent all of our partners in
the right hand system, we have
with the X axis pointing right
and Y, up and Z, back, a
standard coordinate system.
The gyroscope, doesn't have to
do with where the controller is
pointing but how it is moving.
In particular, it encodes the
angular velocity of the
controller above each local axis
t you have the controller flat
on the table.  It is rotating
counter clockwise slowly, one
evolution, two seconds.  What do
you read from that gyroscope in
this case?
The X and Z, it is zero, not
rotating there, the Y examine
axis, what is the row
rotational speed?  5, you're
right.
The numbers are chosen in a
coincidence.
This measures the force of
acceleration on the controller
in each of the local axises.  It
is combined with gravity just
like on the smartphone.
Normally if the controller is
sitting on the desktop you
probably will read something
like 09.80 because of the force
of gravity, it is along the Y
axis.  If you ever read 000 you
should be concerned.  It means
that the user is in outer space
where there is no gravity or
worse that the user tossed the
controller out the window and it
is in free fall towards the
ground which you may say say
rage detected, would you like to
play an easier level?  Also
order me a new controller.
Lastly, we have the touch pad.
This is that circular area, top
of the controller, and it is a
two dimensional surface, we use
X and Y very creatively to
represent the position of the
finger on that surface.
In order to represent
coordinates we think of it as a
square.  We map 00 to the top
left and 11 to the bottom right.
the touch pad has a had clicker.
You can touch the touch pad
and apply pressure to make it
click.  Those two things,
they're different.  The buttons
on the controller are the click
button, precisely this button
that the user presses when they
apply pressure on to the touch
pad.  You also have the app
button, the app button can be
used to do whatever you want,
the menu, switching tools,
whatever we want.
We have the home button on it's
controller, reserved for the
system use.  That's how this
goes back to the home screen.
That little thing on the side,
out of the volume button  s  ,
reserved to the system.  The
click and app
Buttons are available to the app
and you can do whatever you
want for them.  The clicker,
primary action in the app,
painting, drawing, shooting,
selecting, grabbing, anything
like that.  The app button will
be some secondary action or
bringing up a menu.
Again, touch, it is different
from click and this is an
important point.  on the
immolator, there is no such
thing as clicking in touch pad
screen, on the smartphone screen
you double tap to immolate the
click.  We'll give you these
stickers to put on the
controller immolator to get more
of a tactile feel of how it
works.
Let's briefly go in the C++ SDK.
It is a great language, my
favorite language.  The thing
is, it is a powerful language
that has some responsibilities
that come with it.  How does
this sentence end with great
power comes.       comes.... .
Great if things that you have to
debug, that's C++, I like C++.
Hopefully that won't happen to
you.  When your app talks to the
C++ API it talks to the CPI by
of but lives in the other GSO.
The reason why we do
that is because it is difficult
to get two compilers to agree
on how to compile the C++.
Instead the C++ API is living
entirely on your space, a
wrapper around the CIPI.  You
can use it without worrying
about compatibility.  That's
good.
Let's go to code.  If you have
experience, you're thinking
that's a
funny dialect of C++.  It is
java.  In everything, it begins
in java.  Create, up first set
the mode enabled, you enable the
of nice VR applications for the
app.  You have the layout, what
used to be called the Cardboard
layout.  You set the
presentation view as you are
used to doing.  Next, this is an
important part.  You get the
native context.  The GVR native
context, it is an opaque Pointer
which is something that you
need to initial rise the
controller.  When you're in the
C++ land, all you have to do is
get that Pointer and store it
somewhere because you need it
while initial rising the
initializing the
API.  After you do the full
options, you have the action,
you have the options and
Pointer, forget about the
Pointer then because it is only
used to synchronize the headset.
After that, it is low
maintenance, oil changes once in
a while, about I that I mean
pause and resume when the
application is paused or
Next, you can read the
controller state p controller
state is probably the most
complicated part because it
encodes all of the state of the
controller at any given time.
We put together a team, a
creative group of engineers and
told them to come up with a way
to represent a structure that
would encode the controller
state.  What we came up with, it
is instruct controller state.
It is just a strut with data in
it.  Also we made the reach
state method -- read state
method that reads that state.
Its that simple, it doesn't need
to be complicated.  On the draw
frame method, on the rendering
object, you have the read state
and that gives you the latest
known state of the controller,
then you process that in render.
The state has orientation, gyro
XL and those just mean the
current readings of the various
sensors in the controller.  For
a touch pad, we have the touch
that tells you if the user is
currently touching the touch pad
or not.
We have what we call the event
bullions or the transient and
those are the ones that tell you
that a certain event just
happened.  Those are true for
only one frame.  Up render the
frame, that's true.  Next time
you render the frame, it is
false.  It just represents
something that just happened.
The user just started to touch
the touch pad or just stopped
touching the touch pad.  Of
course you have the touch
position in X and Y as we
explained before.
Button states, they work in a
similar way.
You have the click button, app
button, the state, you have the
events.  Recenterring is what
the user does when they notice
the headset and controller are
drifting apart.   They're no
longer center and they pick up
the headset and face the wrong
way.  There is a gesture to do
to make both of them recenter.
That's holding the home button,
pointing forward and releasing
after a second.  The headset and
controller will be recentered
to the same coordinate system.
Before and after.
Basically if before the
coordinates system had die    dy
verged, after they'll point
forward.  You don't actually
need to do anything, the
coordinate systems are handled
but if you want to, you can have
access to those variables and
you main want to pause the game
for example when the user
recenters.  We have the API
status, that tells you about the
general health of the API.  We
have   control API, okay,
everything is well.  The
unavailable, if the service is
unavailable.  Obsolete, if the
client is obsolete.  Service
obsolete, if the service is
obsolete.
Zombie apocalypse and the
undead are taking over the
planet.  That doesn't really
exist, the controller will work
in case of a zombie apocalypse.
Action, if the controller is
connected to the phone, only
nexted,
scanning, connected,
connecting, connected.  The best
state is connected.
I'll tell you how later, this
hases to do with saving the
world -- has to do with saving
the world.  More on had that
later.  You can download the
demo And look at the code that
does those things.
We'll look at the
Unity and SDK, you import that
in your package.  You nets a
prefab under the controller
main.   All you have to do is
drag that prefab in your scene
and then you have the access to
the control API.  In Unity you
added things in the editor and
after you're happy you deploy it
to the device and we support
that because you plug in the
controller immolator directly
and have it work during the edit
mode.  When you're happy, you
can deploy it to the phone and
it will work via wi-fi.
Let's look at an example code.
Let's see we have an on correct,
we want to match the
controller.  What I need to do,
we have to set the objects local
controller to the controller
rotation by calling the GVR,
controller rotation.   That
simple.
Suppose you want to have a
vector are controlling where the
controller is pointing at.  We
have to multiply something to
the vector and that something is
just UVR controller orientation
where you multiply and get the
vector pointing in the same
direction as the controller
pointed.
Let's do some game, you try to
select the project in 3   D
space, using the controller, you
just get a vector from the
controller and then do the usual
cast to figure out which object
was hit.  It is very
straightforward.
Lastly, we have gyro and
Eccelometer, the same
format as we talked about
before.  We have the C++, it is
touching, whether or not the
user is touching currently and
than touchdown and it touch up.
Same thing for button  s  , same
logic with the button, button
up, down, click is the name.
App button up and down.
Then we have, of course, the GVR
controller.  Same
thing, disconnected,
connecting, connected, I
promised to tell you why that
has anything to do with saving
the world.
Imagine you have a game where
you try to save that nice little
planet there, that's just
exactly like earth.   Suppose
that there is this evil enemy,
you're trying to defend it from
the moon.  That makes no sense.
Let's say it is something
that's can have definitely
definitely
not a moon.  You're trying to
save it from the enemy.  The
finaller level, you're about to
deal the final blow and save the
planet and then the controller
disconnects and they're sitting
there unable to do anything,
that's the end of humanity as we
know it.   Because we like
humanity, we should, this is how
you save it.
Any time the controller state is
anything other than the
connection to stay connected,
that's when you pause the game
and let the user reconnect the
controller to continue to play.
We talked a bunch about all the
features of the controller.  We
talked about the SDKs and again
you can go to developer/VR now
and download the app if you
want, you can get started
developing today.
In the beginning I showed you
this.  Actually I lied a bit.  T
hat's not 100% true.  The only
thing that's standing between
user and happiness, it is not
just code, there is more to
happiness than code.
Surprisingly.  You actually need
design.  If you're asking the
difference between code and
design the way I like to think
about it, code is when you're
doing the thing right.  Design,
it is when you're doing the
right thing.  In order to talk
to you a bit more about how to
do the right thing I would like
to welcome Ryan Hipple from
Schell Games.
>> RYAN HIPPLE: Hello, everyone.
I'm I'm Francisco Souki.
>> I'm Ryan Hipple.
>> FRANCISCO SOUKI: We spent a
month just make  ing cool stuff
for the controller.  We have
made 17 demos and our goal was
to play around with the
controller, see what feels right
and we're using the same the
tools that would be available to
you today if you were to
develop, the headset, the lamer
controller, the Unity making all
of the games.
We'll take you through some of
the demo we made and we learned
a lot from and
tell you about the design on my
side and the code on Ryan's
side.  To start, I will say that
like you heard these guys say,
this controller has a lot of
sensors, a lot of data, gives
you a lot of power and me as a
designer when I saw this I was
like this looks cool, I guess,
yeah.  Ryan, you know how to
interpret this stuff, so my
vision for this is itch a
controller in my hand, can we
make something that feels to the
player like they're holding
something, like
a controller
>> RYAN HIPPLE: How about a had
game of tennis or a had brick
breaking game or combine the two
and make a tennis brick
breaking game.  We have the
orientation from the controller
to control the rotation of the
at the in us racket that pivots
around the body of the player
and we have a natural range of
the tennis racket that way where
you can do your forehands and
backhand and it is rotated
around to the right spot.  On
the more game design side of
this we're focusing on
leveraging the very accurate
orientation we have from the SDK
and use that to make sure that
when you hit the balls they're
upwards if you're tilting the
wrist up or down, and you make
them go to the left or the
right.  In order to do that,
we're cheating the collisions in
the game a lot to make the game
easy to hit and putting the
game challenge in there by
forcing the player to use that
accurate aim in order to twist
their wrist to get the ball
exactly at the panel that they
want to smash.
>> FRANCISCO SOUKI: Like Ryan
said, it is in the wrist.   We
do a bit of timing.  If you
swing early, you go that way.
Late, it goes that way.  You
don't have to worry about the
position of the ball or how to
hit the ball.  It is about your
aiming with the wrist.  It was
very fun, the play testers loved
it -- shall I say that the play
testers that love skill games
loved it.  Play testers that
maybe are not fond of tennis or
skill games were not hot on it.
My immediate thought was why
don't we try some more
traditional emotion kind of
gesture detection and see how
they feel about that.
>> RYAN HIPPLE: In our more
traditional motion control game
we have the warrior game.  You
see that in the video there.
Players trying to slash at
objects before they hit a
warrior avatar and this is used
by detecting a few simple
gestures with the controller and
you use the gyroscope readings
here.  The gyroscope readings
are the perfect thing for this,
they tell I how fast the player
is moving the controller.  When
the movement speed is exceeding
some threshold we need to use
we'll figure out how -- what
direction we're going and we'll
look in a left, right, upper,
left flash and we use that with
a avatar with a sword that gets
to break stuff.
>> FRANCISCO SOUKI: This works
about you you have a bit of I'm
if here standing getting a
swiping affect.  Every other
swiping game before has been
made and our players that tried
the tennis first were like I
want that one to one, why aren't
you giving me gestures.
Anything we can do to this game
to   get that one to one back
but not compromise to the core
mechanic?
>> RYAN HIPPLE: There is.
This is where we one up the
traditional motion control games
because we have that accurate
orientation.  By maintaining the
game play we already have with
the slash gestures we can use
the orientation to power the
animation on the character and
the scene and we use that to
blend between several animations
or several poses and the sword
on this warrior character should
always be reflecting the
orientation that a player is
holding the controller.
Additionally, one issue with our
first approach, if you swiped
to the left you do a sword slash
to the left.  If you're
twisting the controller that's
now an upward swipe.   You get
around that by multiplying or
transforming your gyroscope
readings by the orientation
which will give you something
that's more of a world
space/detection.  No matter how
they twist the calendar it will
slash according to the movement
of the player.
>> You can definitely take the
gesture controls to the next
level but I want to go back to
that one to one.
Holding the object in my hand,
examining, trying it out, I was
hoping maybe instead of aiming
far away we can give them, the
players something that's more
close range to play
with.
>> RYAN HIPPLE: In our demo, we
play it with a massive hammer.
We take it and treat each thing
differently.   Swinging the
hammer, the pitch it axis, the X
axis powering the position,
rotation of the hammer to keep a
bit of a constraint on that not
clicking through the keys and
breaking immersion.  We have the
ability to point, the heading,
the yall of the controller in
order to aim at what keys the
player is going to hit to play
what notes they want to play.
On top of that we're using a bit
of the camera rotation so you
notice in the video here that
the field of play is much
broader than what you can see
with just one screen.  You turn
your head and look to the left
or the right.  We're using that
to cheat a bit and make sure
that the players is going to hit
the thing they're focusing on
so that they move their hand
quickly and they're not throwing
off the direction of the
hammer.  We're doing some aim
assist in this game.
>> FRANCISCO SOUKI: And in this
demo you can tell the players
are starting to feel things
start to gel.
They love the closely held
object and you can usually as a
game designer watching them
play, you can watch them go
through three stages.  The first
stage, they jump in the world,
they see they're holding a
hammer, the wrist thing, the
hammer does the wrist thing for
them.  That's great, the
controller is working perfectly
there.
Then they realize the keys are
in a curved shape so they look
around.  They are using that
sort of VR space looking all
around.  Then they identify any
key that they want to play and
they go for the thing and it
works.  It is a combination of
where you're looking and how
you're swinging, when that feels
right, and when the world holds
up to what they want to do as
players, it feels great for
them.   That's where the
platform really shines.
That combination helped
improve their perceived accuracy
and so I'm thinking can we use
that combination or that aiming
and that closely held object to
maybe let them do something that
they wish they could do but
they can't do in real life?
>> RYAN HIPPLE: If anyone
here actually tried to throw a
boom ring, anyone
boomerang?  It is incredibly
disappointing.  There is a
powerful technique only mastered
by a few, you throw it, it
doesn't go where you want it to
go back, where you want it to
go, there is an expectation of
this, you see the shape and feel
like I should throw this, it
should go where I want it to and
snap right back to me.  This is
where we take the orientation
we have from the headset again
and use it as an aim assist.
Where the player is looking in
this demo will drive where the
curve of the boomerang goes.
The goal is to break as many of
the floating targets as you can
with a single throw.  You use
the head for aiming and the
controller is free for the
throwing it.  You use the
similar thing for the sword
slashes here, you use the
gyroscope reading its and if it
is above a certain threshold it
triggers that throw.   Looking
where you want to throw and
doing the throw gesture will get
that out there.
Additionally to maintain the
immersion here, we have the
orientation to make sure the
boom ring
boomerang rotates to
reflect that in the hands, you
so he that in the videos here,
that little bit of movement is
keeping it, grounding the player
between the two worlds.
>> FRANCISCO SOUKI: This video
is about empowering the player
and about letting them
experience their -- how they
feel it, throwing the boomerang,
how it should feel.
Tall skinny table like boom, I
want to put in that exit sign,
bam, it goes there.
It is less about very precise
one to one matching of the thing
that they're pointing to or the
exact hand movement and more
about the precise matching and
the boomerang in their hand
combined with the aim assist
that is provided to us.  It is
about interpreting all of those
-- all of that data we get and
letting the player fulfill what
they think it should play like.
What we realize at this point
though, we haven't touched touch
pad at all.  It is about the
swinging, all about the pointing
and the head.   Touch pads are
just the number one thing that
you should use in games, right?
Whether it is a Joy stick, a
virtual touch pad, we used touch
pads all the time for all of
our games, can we just put
something that we normally make
in a normal platform a different
platform?  A non-profit
entities VR platform in this
special place with this touch
pad?  Does it hold up?
>> RYAN HIPPLE: Of course we
can.
Using the touch pad on the
controller we can use that as a
traditional D pad control.  This
is something that players will
immediately be familiar with.  I
t is the type of games that had
existed since almost the
beginning of games.  In our
adventure game demo the player
controls a little character
walking around using that D pad
and then the nice thing about
this, it frees up the headset
now the, it functions as the
camera control, a problematic
scheme, you can look around the
world, it adds a sense ever
exploration, you see more than
you would be able to if you had
to have this automatic follow
camera.  Those controls, we have
them a little bit specialized
for the layout here.   We have
the character in an environment
that it circles the player and
their perspective, so when you
want to move the character along
that path we have it so that it
is a circular-based path, you
hold it to the right and this
player will trace a circle, the
character will trace a circle
around the player
making it much easier to
navigate, making it easier to
have the player move forward
through the world and of course
in this demo we have it end up
with the player meeting the
character they have controlled
this entire time.
We use a bit of the gesture
controls that we talked about
before and the click pad in
order to use abilities that
trigger things in this
environment and vice president
light puzzles and collection
mechanics as you see.
Is it
>> FRANCISCO SOUKI: When you
make your own adventure games
you'll realize that you can use
a touch pad for movement, no
problem, it feels great.  It
will free up all of the other
stuff in the controller for you
to explore that space.
This is the extent of the demo
we made.  Everything you see
here, it is the totality of the
spaces we explored.   What that
leaves is a lot of open space
for you to try to take it to the
next level however you want to.
In this case, the click,
gestures, the pointing, all of
that, it is freed up, it is not
something that you need to use
and the touch pad feels familiar
to the players.  It is
recognizable so you can truly
use those interactions because
the player doesn't have to think
twice about how to use the
touch pad to move the character.
we figured out the touch pad
was good for a character?
>> RYAN HIPPLE: Good for one
player, let's see if we can
control multiple characters.  In
the realtime strategic
innovation is gee style demo we
have the orientation that we
have from the controller, from
the SDK using that to ray cast
in the world and you can use
that to point to select a
character and point to had
direct them somewhere and you
can also drag select to select
multiple characters in the world
and give them instructions at
the same time.  You can also use
the gyroscope gestures again
like we did for the sword slash
and a lot of the games to
trigger multiple actions that
the characters can do.  In this
we have a few simple   puzzle
mechanics that let's the player
explore the world and you're
using the orientation from the
headset and taking control of
the camera very naturally with
just the players look vector.
this feel good in this platform!
We love this demo.  Play
testers love this demo.   People
couldn't put it down until they
figure out the full puzzle that
we had.  The interaction was
empowering them to control the
characters, how they wanted to
control the characters.
We draw a line from the
controller position to the
target and it keeps players
aware of the orientation of the
controller at every time.
That interface, it makes it easy
for you to control one
character or several characters
and similar to the adventure
game that you saw before, the
touch pad game, freeing up the
controller,'s special hadly
because you can -- especially
you can use the whole world and
pace out the level and to
control where the player is
looking at any given time.  The
camera movement doesn't need to
be tied to the controller in
anyway.  If your mind is going
like how can I use that mechanic
to make an RTS or make a
strategy game, aic at a ticks
game, any multicharacter control
game, that drag to select, all
of that, that's where it should
be   going because the platform
is really good for it.  What we
thought though, to figure out
how to sort of get the most of
the orientation controls, the
most of the character control,
can we marry them together? we
can in the sky ship demo, the
players, they control a gliding
air ship through an environment
dodging obstacles picking up
coins along the way.  This is
simple on the input side.  We're
just using the orientation that
we get.  This let's us
essentially just point and click
-- no clicking, sorry, point to
guide this glider around the
environment and using the pitch
and roll, the jall, like an
actual aircraft to get it to
move around the environment.  H
aving the roller or the twist as
well, it is really nice for
this, should the mood strike
you, you can do a barrel roll.
>> FRANCISCO SOUKI: Yes. No
clicking Ryan said because the
clicking is freed up here for
you to do whatever you may want
to do in a had flying ship.
When you play this, it feels
like you're handling a toy plane
and you're threading it through
space all through the rings p
the handshake being, it is not a
big problem here.  You control
how wide the gaps are with the
rings, the spaces that you're
trying to fit the ship through.
That counters a lot
of the precision of your own
hand translating into the world
and it does allow you to orient
the ship sort of however you
want as you're flying with it.
This is one that play testers
couldn't put down.  We just keep
the rings coming and they will
keep playing and as long as you
give them a goal of collect 10
coins and pass it along they'll
just stay in there doing it all
the time.  It feels good.  The
pillars, they're there, you
don't get the motion sickness
from moving forward, you're
stationary and the world moves
in front of you.  You
have no motion sickness.
At that point, we're feeling
confident and we're like, okay,
we seem to have this thing
figured out, it is constrained
to a plane but maybe we can
breakout of that plane and go
bigger, what I want to do, I
want to feel like I'm flying a
kite but I'm controlling this
great creature that I summoned
>> RYAN HIPPLE: Here be the
dragons.  Our dragon demo, they
control a massive dragon using
the controller orientation and
they're pointing the controller
where they want the dragon to go
to   give immediate feedback we
have a dollar, a statue of the
dragon in front of the camera.
This is goal orientation.  We
have learned this in other
demos, you want to maintain the
relationship between the
controller and a physical object
in the environment.
In order to make the dragon feel
like a massive entity we have
that point towards that vector
that you're guiding it towards
and have it almost
lumbar along in this
twisted path collecting,
destroying the floating objects.
>> FRANCISCO SOUKI: You get the
source to play with these, fire
it up, point it and watch the
dragon come at you and we have
added things to take advantage
of that VR.   There is a slight
camera shake which sounds like
what, you're shaking the players
camera and anyone before tell
you what you can't do in VR,
try, see if it works or not, it
works here.  It is a slight
shake and it is combined with
the position of the a you had yo
of the dragon so you really
feel like you're sharing the
space with this big creature and
you're doing this dance with
it.  It is big, heavy, it
handles like a big, heavy
creature and you're dancing with
it through space and trying to
eat up big structures and you
point it at your sever and it is
coming to you, and it tries to
eat the thing next to you, it is
great!  It feels really good!
This is really I think
showcasing what the daydream can
do, a lot, especially when you
combine this headset with the
controller and you have the epic
flyovers with the
dragon.  It feels great.
We have done the dragon,
boomerang, the music, we have 17
is things in total.  What's
left for us to do?  Should we
give people what they have
been asking for all along?
>> RYAN HIPPLE: You have seen it
plenty, here be the pancakes!
In this demo we're using the
orientation to had flip these
pancakes and then we have a very
advanced Pancake physics engine
we're running to make sure
they're moving as they should.
In reality it is actually just
using the basic game physics
system here and having a pan
with thely on it as the
collision structure works
really, really well.  This
orientation, it gives you a
really nice flip gesture to do
and we're not doing the gesture
detection, it is just natural
how the physics simulation pairs
up with having the raw
orientation input.
It turns out to be a very, very
fun thing to do.  We did do a
bit of active Pancake assist
here to make sure that the
pancakes don't get out of reach.
Overall, it is a natural, fun
demo.
>> The pancakes, they kind of
fit what is awesome about
daydream, which is you see the
Pancake demo, people are
tweeting about it from the
keynote, my God, I want to
flippen pancakes in VR, you get
in there, flip pancakes and it
plays how you look, you're
flipping the pancakes and you're
like, yes, got it!  When the
platform allows you to do
exactly what it looks like and
feels like what it looks like
and what it should feel like,
that's when you know it is a big
win.
eat the pancakes in VR?
>> FRANCISCO SOUKI: That's the
next step.
>> RYAN HIPPLE: We built 17
demos.  178 demos like these and
we did that in a little over a
month.  All of the tools we had
to do this, it was the SDK,
Bruno talked about that, the
controller immolator with a
phone as the input device and
the Nexus6P with Cardboard to
develop with.   All of them are
out there, available now, if the
source code for all of data
demos we built should be
there for a starting point to
play around with, start making
great games with this platform.
We really feel like the things
we put together only really
scratch the surface of what we
can do with daydream and what to
do with this amazing
controller.  What will you
build?
Thank you.
of mobile app it design:
Delight users and drive
conversions.
Principles of mobile app
it design:  Delight users and
drive conversions.
Principle of mobile app design:
Delight users and drive
conversions.
Principle of mobile app
design:  Delight users and
drive conversions.
Principle of mobile app design:
Delight users and
drive conversions. Principle of
mobile app design:  Delight
users and
drive conversions.
>> JENNIFER GOVE: Hello,
everyone!  How much are you all!
Great!  A wonderful crowd!
Thank you for coming to my talk
today.
My name is
Jenny gove and I'm a user
experience researcher at Google.
I have been here now this
month for ten years and I heard
that
coincides --
[Applause]
>> JENNIFER GOVE: Thank you!
That coincides with the number
of years we have been having I/O
conferences.  A double
anniversary.  That's fun.
This afternoon we'll talk about
developing great apps and
creating principles of mobile
app design that I wants to share
with you so that puck   create
great experiences for your users
-- so that we can create great
experiences for your users.
Why is this important?  It is
important, there is 1.   1.5
million apps in each of the app
stores as we know.   There is a
lot of -- there is a lot of
competition out there.  You
don't want your app to suffer
from userrablety flaws.  I think
that the userrablety flaws on
the user experience issues can
contribute to the lack of
engagement that some apps have.
For example, we have learned
that things like 25% of apps
sometimes don't get used more
than once.  34% of apps are not
opened more than 11 times.
These statistics are around with
regard to, you know, app
engagement, reengagement.  We're
doing a lot of work on that
issue itself hat Google with
certain products we're bringing
out.   I think it is also on us
to really work on our user
experience, our usability issues
in our apps.
I'm going to tell you about
three things in the rest of my
talk:  I'll tell you about a
story that I had with an
experience with an app recently;
I'll tell you about a study we
found to understand what makes a
really great app experience;
I'll go through some of the
principles that we have
published online so that you can
understand some key things that
you can do to make your app
experience better.   Within
those principles I have a number
of resources for you as well
that can help you along the way.
vacation with my family -- here
we are, having a wonderful time
in Florida, that's me and my
partner, my kids.  Before we
went on vacation I set up a
series of hotels for us to stay
at.  It was a self-driving tour,
I prebooked them on my laptop.
When I got to Florida I found a
lot of hotels had started to
use -- making great use of new
technologies, apps specifically
in order to give me some really
seamless experiences on my trip.
They do things now like
enabling me to check in before I
get there so just like I can
for an airplane and enabling me
to go straight to my room in
order to open the door, just
with the app.  That's pretty
cool.    I was blown away by the
new things they were able to
do.
What happened when I was on
vacation was the notification to
check in came while I was
standing in line at something
like this, the rollercoaster at
the theme park.   It asked me
did I want to check in.  It also
asked me did I want to choose
my own room or did I want to let
them choose for me.  Well, it
when I booked I remembered there
was a text field and it asked
me if I had got any requests, I
put in that I wanted to have a
Seaview.  I knew at the next
hotel that there was this
beautiful   pristine beach.  I
ordered a room with a balcony
and I really wanted this
wonderful experience looking out
over the sea.  I didn't know
whether that -- you know,
whether that experience on the
laptop would translate into this
app experience I was now faced
with.  I was a bit concerned
about that.  You know, I thought
that I may have a better
opportunity of choosing my own
room rather than letting them
choose for me, kind of always
better to take it in your own
hands, right?
I decided to choose my own room.
The experience that they gave
me was pretty good on a mobile
divide.             device.  It
worked, it looksal challenging
in terms of real estate, it
worked out well.  They laid out
the rooms and clearly labeled if
the rooms were taken or open.
It was only one problem though,
that was I had no idea which way
the sea was facing.   You know,
which way the hotel was facing
in front of the sea.  I was in
line and trying to figure out
how to solve this.  The of
there                There were
work arounds I didn't think
about, going to look on Google
maps I could figure it out,
Google Images, in this case, the
hotel, it was -- I decided to
use a rule of thumb and I
decided to think that the side
with the most taken rooms was
probably the side that was
facing the sea.   I decided to
choose room 730 over here.
We got to the hotel, took up all
the bags, you know what's going
to happen, don't you?
I got a view that looked a
little bit like this!: Big
disappointment.
What did I have to do then?  I
had to go all the way down again
to reception which I thought I
would bypass by using the app,
talk to the receptionist, though
extremely helpful, a lovely
hotel, fixed it for me, and in
the end we went back up, a
different floor, went to the
hotel, and I got a view that was
much more like this.
Beautiful.  This is actually
Florida.  It looks like the
bahamas or something.  It was
really, really nice.
The in-person guest service was
required, human intervention was
required because the app hadn't
really delivered the service I
had hoped it would.  It had done
so well I was really taken with
this new technology I could
use.  It fell short because it
hadn't delivered this critical
piece of information for me,
which was, you know, I just
needed some information on the
map.  In this case, I just
needed a view of the ocean,
perhaps a few waves  , just some
orientation.
So for me, it was pretty
critical that my view was of
this beautiful beach rather than
this car park.
You know, it could have been
even more critical than my, you
know, very dear to me vacation,
it could have been an event
manager booking for a client,
perhaps it could have been
people booking for guests for a
wedding or something.
one lesson is clear, that's
how we as developers and
designers really need to
understand the whole flow that
our users are going through and
where that breaks down.  This is
cool, new technology, I had to
sort of backtrack through the
whole thing and do those things
that the app was supposedly
saving me from doing.  Really
understanding that experience
from beginning to end.
I think it on mobile, it is
really those little things that
we don't realize we need to
cover.  That's why we really
need to understand the user
perspective and experience with
that.
My talk will be about things
like that, how we can fix them.
Let me give you a little
history.  It a couple of years
ago we found that a lot of
experiences on the mobile app
were particularly problematic
for people.  We conducted a
large study and tried to
understand where things weren't
being implemented right for the
mobile wear and where we could
do better and we released a set
of 25 principles for the mobile
web.  Those have done really
well.  People have used them as
a
kind of initial step in making a
good foray in providing a
better mobile experience on the
mobile web.   As well as we have
done, people have come back
saying this is great but what
about my app, what can you tell
me about my app?  I have had a
lot of calls to do another study
and a study on apps.  We have
done that.  More recently we
have looked at native apps in
the study and so the principles
I'll present to you today are
the result of that work.
In this study we have been able
to understand patterns that need
to pull user experiences and
then luckily and happily we were
able to see where some
companies have implemented
things in a better way and
understand why those
patterns work better and bring
them to you.
It is important for us to really
understand this well so we can
be confident in the principles
that we're telling you about and
you can be confident in
implementing them in your own
products.  In order to do the
study, we partnered with a
company called Answer Lab, very
user experience consultancy
based in San Francisco.  We
partnered with them because they
could help us scale.  We want
thed the study to be pretty --
we
wanted the study be to large
scale.  Wet studied interaction
on 100 different apps on mobile.
These ranged from large
retailers through to smaller
service providers.  We looked at
news apps, we looked at many
different sorts of   services,
grocery, travel services,
retail, small and big companies.
We didn't look at games as
part of this.  That was on
purpose because we felt that
would weaken or dilute the
principles.  We think that games
probably have a whole different
set of principles.  Aside from
that, we looked across wide
range of verticals.
We conducted the studies in San
Francisco, Chicago and New York
City.
There were 103 participants that
took part in this study.  For
usability study, that's really
big.  They came in to the lab
individually each for 90
minutes, 155 hours of usability
studies.  If you stayed up all
night and all day, that would be
almost a week with no breaks or
-- in reality it is almost like
four weeks of working weeks.
A large study
indeed.  That's because we
wanted to cover the different
verticals.
What we did in the study, people
came in the study and during
the 90 minutes they were able to
use around 6 apps to really get
into good tasks for each of
owes.  They brought in their own
phones with them.  That was
because we wanted them to be
really familiar with the phone,
we didn't want any problems
because it was a different
device or not used to the back
button or anything like that.
50% on IoS.  What did we do when
they were in the study?
We had different tasks and
different scenarios set up for
them.  We did our best to make
that task kind of mean something
to them as well so they
couldn't do what we
call satisfying, doing the task
as quick as they can in -- we
wanted them to care about the
task.  We talked to them about
things that they cared about,
and this example we may talk to
them about their favorite food
and understand what it is from
them first before anyone going
to ask them to see if they could
order it for dinner that
evening.  We had them speak out
loud using what's called in
usability terminology think
allowed protocol.  We did that
so that we could understand the
pain points that they hit as
they were   going through the
different tasks that they were
doing and we could understand
where things flowed really
smoothly for them.
Having done that, we took the
data, there was a lot of data as
you can imagine from that much
usability material and we
brought it down to 25 principles
so that this is something that
you can take and understand and
apply to had your own apps.  We
have categorized the principles
in 6 chapters.  Before I go into
them, I want to explain how we
actually got to the 25.  In
order to make it into the 25
principles it we had to see
that this was a problem across a
wide range of verticals and we
had to see that it was a fairly
common problem.  We did
encounter more things than 25
things that were a problematic
in apps, but we wanted to make
sure that we were hit  ing the
biggest problems and that we
also saw better ways that these
could be implemented.
different chapters that we have
are around navigation and
exploration, in app search,
commas and conversions,
registration, form entry,
usability and comprehension.
We have got 25 of these
different
principles and here in this
talk I'm just going to go into
two principles from each of the
chapters.  The rest of the
principles are available to you
online.  I have also pulled
together some resources for you
that can help with
implementation of some things
you see here, that may be a good
time to take a picture of the
screen as it is a resource to
look into in your own time in
more detail.
app navigation and exploration.
This chapter, it is about
guiding users to the content
that they're looking for
quickly.  We brought together a
set of key principles to have
you create effective, delightful
app navigation.  Let's take a
look at two of these now.
A feature that can be really
rough       of great helper to
users is auto detection of
location.  Don't assume that the
location-based tasker is
basically based in the current
location without exception.  I
think we saw this too often.
It is a really great thing to
implement and to help, you know,
create a seamless experience
for users when but want
something located where they
are.  We basically saw it over
applied without a way of
enabling people to change their
location.
In this example, somebody is
looking for a hotel tonight and
they're looking for a hotel near
where they are.
Unfortunately, while they can't
change location, the only way to
do it, to change locations, it
is to go through settings.  We
saw this problem in not only
travel apps but we saw it in
retail apps, we saw use cases of
people wanting to find
something in a store, but
perhaps it was located near
where their parents live and
they wanted to figure out, you
know, if it was in the store
near them so that they could
tell their parents about that.
basically were seeing too many
use   cases that were outside of
this scenario.  In travel we
saw it where people would turn
up for their transportation and
the hotel that they wanted to
book was at the other end, and
the other end of the train line
and they had to now book the
hotel and they're not in the
place where they're needing the
hotel at the time.  A much
better scenario is to still
enable people to use the current
location, but to provide the
resource for them to change that
well.
Basically great, great
technology here that definitely
I encourage you to use but it is
kind of overapplied without
using some of the screen real
estate to enable them to had
change location.
If you do want to use that auto
detecting location then Google
place API allows you to discover
that currently supported
location and we have a short
link for you there to get to
that
material.
Another aspect of app navigation
and exploration that we saw a
fair bit with apps is moving
people from the app to the
mobile web.  You can see in the
way that I have written this
principle that, you know, there
are issues with doing this,
where the app to web transitions
are needed, where needed, make
them frictionless.  The question
is are they really needed?
We're trying here to make
technologies to make this a lot
smoother, this transition where
you need to do it.  You know, at
the moment we still see at
least some sort of performance
hit.  Really consider whether
you have to push people out to
the mobile web when they're in
the app experience right now.  T
hen make them frictionless so --
in this example we have got
somebody who is checking in for
a flight.  This can be a usual
situation where people are moved
out to the mobile web.  What we
often saw and not just in
travel apps but other scenarios
as well we saw the experience
change fundamentally.  We saw
something like this.
It can sometimes happen I think
because of the organizational
structure of teams.  This is the
app team and this is the mobile
web team.  They haven't been
talking enough.
some companies are doing a
better job of bringing the teams
together to enable them to plan
the user experience, the look
and feel, and how content is
laid out.  Then separating out
for the actual implementation on
the different platforms and a
much better experience is when
companies have been really
thoughtful about this and you
can make that look and feel very
seamless even though you're
just moving out, right out to
the mobile web.
The on Android we're doing work
on this.  We have some
technology custom
tabs to look into.  It is
really helpful for enabling you
to do things like changing the
tool bar color and exiting and
entering animations to make that
whole process of moving from
the app to the mobile web more
seamless.
importance of great in-app
search, they can't be
underestimated.  Let's talk
about a couple of crucial search
implementations.  Prominently
displaying the search field, we
found this back when we did the
mobile web study about the
importance of search.  On the
poor example we have search in a
place where people expect to
look for it.  It
is not how they expect to find
it as a text, a piece of text
here.  What we saw in the study
was people kind of did have
frustration looking around for
search.  Sometimes it was hidden
under a menu.  It sounds like
one of the most obvious things
but I think what my summary of
what I saw in the study was the
developers and designers aren't
implementing persistent search
field enough.  We advise a
persistent search field should
be included when searches are
really quite a significant part
of your experience in your app.
I think what's happening is
plenty of people are thinking
that search is important, but
not that
important to devote the screen
real estate to.
You know, check that out in your
app.  Should you give it more
prominence than you currently
are?
We have advice on this in
material design.  We have a
persistent search putting in a
search field and we also have
expandable search where we have
the looking glass icon that can
be expanded for search, of
course.  Think about the
prominence of search in your app
and how it really matters to
people when making that decision
about which type of search you
should implement.
Then for implementation details,
we have the search dialogue and
the search widget.  This link
will take you to more
information about that.
What about filter and sort
options?  Hugely important.
Again we often saw they were
hidden or sort of further down
and people couldn't get to them
as much as they needed.   That's
what the study that we did
recently showed.    ou know, we
saw great implementations of it
and still there is more work to
be done.  Things like getting
down to 242 results for search
with no way to filter, sort them
further.  A better
implementation is to have a
really nice clear button filter,
people can see that quite
clearly and easily and this
example for a panel, it the
panel sliding out with all of
the right sort of search options
for them.   You can sort   by
best match, latest collection,
that kind of thing.  One thing I
saw with filters like this was
some companies were taking, for
example, the sizing away when
the inventory wasn't available.
That caused a problem for
people.  They didn't know if
they would ever have their size
in stock.  Imagine you know
extra small being taken away
just because it wasn't in stock,
people didn't know if it would
come back.  Better experience
for that is something like, you
know, enabling them to perhaps
sign up to find out when it is
back in stock.  He certainly
showing it, showing it
in a stable state, it is good.
another thing I like about this
design, it is very clear when
you're clearing the filters or
applying the filters in a
separate check at the top in
order to close the panel so that
there is not confusion about
what closing the panel does.
Keeping on this topic of search
we have other methods that will
help with people with their
search.  One of those, adding
custom suggestions that can be
created from data in your
application, so that can really
help people with their search.
Another one, recent quarry
suggestions.  All these
technologies and facilities can
make that search experience
better.  Thinking through the
search experience in more depth
is a good topic.
enough experience for finding,
learning about, purchasing
products.  Let's look at a
couple of things that the study
revealed about conversions and
helping to drive that conversion
experience.
Enabling comparison shopping
features.  In this example on
the left here we're in a real
estate app here and people are
just -- they're only able to
scroll down and look at the
different homes.  Anything they
like, they have to commit to
memory.  People, you know,   us,
you, me, we're all cognitive
meisers that don't want to use
our brain that much.  The user
is using their brain,
remembering where they saw
things, so forth.  We can do
better.
Some of those things that we saw
that were implemented to help
people in this way were letting
people kind of book mark items
that they saw so that they can
compare them.  It still is
pretty difficult on mobile to do
this.  Still anything we can do
helps.  The example I will show
you here, it enabled people to
compare and then you can see it
is quite constrained with the
size of the phone.  Still you're
bringing that information
together.  It means that they
could ignore all of the other
homes they don't care about.
They can compare the bedrooms
it, they can compare the
bathrooms, the cost of the home,
so forth.     know this is
needed because in the study we
saw people do work arounds for
this.  In retail we saw people
add items to their cart just so
that they could look at them all
in the same place.  That was
the users that thought about
doing that.
Other people struggled.
We know that this is needed.  T
hink   about the comparisons and
the browsing experience
that people are needing within
your app.
Then making it easy to add and
manage payment methods.   I
actually came across a poor
example of this the other day.
It was when I went to purchase
-- I was going on vacation again
-- I like to go on vacation --
I was making a reservation for a
rental home.  I got to the
point where I needed to update
my cards.  My model in my head
was a new card had arrived and
it is simply the same card as
before, it just had a new date
on it.  In my mind my mental
model, that's the same card,
just needs replacing, it is not
a new payment method.  I
expected to be able to edit my
existing card.  There was no
facility to do that.  I kind of
had to understand the developer
model that I needed to add a new
payment method.
to the point where they're
supposed to be checking out, but
there is no way to edit card or
add a new card.  That's
somewhere else, in some other
settings.  You know, most of us
don't think -- well, you know,
I'm going to wake up in the
morning and think I need to
manage my payment methods in the
app kind of as a separate
activity.  We tend to think
about it when we need to do it
when we come to pay.
This is a problem here.  In this
example it is much better.
There is an option to edit
existing cards, to add a new
payment method, and provide
multiple payment methods here
and lead people to a very clean
form design here when the user
is chosen to pick -- to add a
new credit card and they can
even scan their card if they
wish to.  Making that experience
nice and
clean.
A facility we offer at Google,
Android Pay, making that a
choice to pay.  The idea, it is
simple for the user  , seamless
for the user to pay through
Android Pay and this is a talk I
think about it at I/O and more
information that puck get at
this link.
really popular with, you know,
companies and developers because
it seems to be that that's
where we can get engagement from
the user and that's where the
user commits to us.  We have
known for a long time that
providing the registration
barriers upfront can be a big
hurdle for people to get to.  It
is better to offer them
something first so that they can
feel -- start to feel
engagement from their side to
the company.  There's a couple
of other things I want to talk
about today with regard to
registration.
We saw users struggle with
signing in and signing up.   It
is a tricky thing h we often see
users starting to fill out a
form if provided one and
realizing that they were signing
in when they were supposed to
be signing up and vice versa.
It probably happened to all of
us.
We found better experience when
people were just given the
option to sign in or register,
the words, they were very
different, they could
differentiate them and we could
channel them down the right kind
of route so that they didn't
get into that
model.
We have lots of solutions for
registration and identity at
Google.  We have a whole
identity platform that I would
encourage you to look at.  It is
basically an all-system and has
several components and
different choices for you to
make.  One of these, sign-in for
Android, it enands a user to
sign in with the different
credentials on Google, the
intent is to make that process
more seamless and simple for
them.
Talking of that, there are other
ways to make password
authentication a frictionless
experience.  We have all been in
this situation where it just
doesn't work for us.  It is
quite painful on mobile to put
your password in and it is not
working.  It can be even worse
in apps because we often found
this is a had place where people
were sent back out to the
mobile web.
You're in that loop again and
that's even more aggravating.
We have talked about one
solution for easing that
enabling people to sign in.  A
nother one that we saw that's
becoming much more popular is
fingerprint signin.  In our
study we found that people were
pretty happy about this.   They
like the idea very much of doing
this.  This is a good thing to
look
into.  We have more
implementation details for you
here by using fingerprint scans
on supported devices.
Smart lock, another part of
our identity system enabling you
to automatically sign users
into the app using credentials
that they have saved.  That's
another really good one.  Part
of this federated identity
provision.
If you haven't got that far with
users, there is also sign in
hints.  This allows us to use
the credit        credentials
and give hints for the user
name, email address, everything
is done to ease that sign in
hurdle.
design about form entry for
years and years.  We did lots of
work on form entry for desktops
and when we went to the mobile
web we kind of had to relearn
all of that again and   again.
You will remember when the forms
used to be really, really tiny,
and you had to expand them to
fill out the form.  It has been
better with apps because we're
designing forms from the get go
for the mobile devices.
I'm pleased to say, I think we
have come a long way.   There is
still things we saw in our
study that could be
improved.  This is Sunday
building user friendly forms  .
I saw some apps requiring users
to do a lot of work on their
part, putting the curser in
several different fields for
their phone numbers, things like
this, it takes a lot of effort
on the part of the user.  Also
not being able to see what form
fields were coming up was a
problem for users.  It was hard
for them to.
Build their mental model of what
they were filling in next.  If
caused them frustration and was
definitely a friction point.
engagement here is doing more
work on the back end.  You know,
whether the user wants to write
in their phone number with
dashes in between the numbers,
with spaces in between the
numbers, or just as one long
field, we need to cater for that
and make it -- it is a bit more
work for us on the development
side, but it makes it a whole
lot easier for the user to
understand what they're doing
and not get, you know, an error
return.
Also, you know, whether there
are errors providing those in
line is really helpful and here
we have an app that does a good
job of moving the form up the
field as the user fills it in
and we found that was a very of
advantage to users.
it was an advantage to users.
We have great text fields
through material design and it
talks about the aspects of
creating a
good form.
Specifically for places, we can
use places auto complete as part
of the places API again helping
for filling in those form
fields that require location.
Another aspect to form design is
matching the coat board with
the required text inputs.  This
is a fairly well-known thing to
do.  We saw significant apps not
doing this well.  When the user
puts the curser in the credit
card field and you have this in
your app, check it out.  Is it
doing the right thing, right?
This example here, it is not
doing the right thing, the user
is left with this keyboard and
they don't have anyway of
getting the right keyboard up,
not -- you now, not usually they
hit the number key over here
and then they'll get the
keyboard with the numbers along
the top as opposed to designing
that appropriately and when the
curser is in there bringing up
the numeric keyboard for them.
Little things like this.  These
things add up and checking out
the form design in this way, it
is helpful for people.
We have information on
specifying input methods and the
correct keyboard that you can
find at this
link.  Lastsly, usability,
comprehension.  Those are the
small things to do that we saw
in studies throughout the app to
make a more seamless experience
for users.  It can be critical
for ensuring a good user
experience and not having users
get stuck or abandon their
experience at any point.  This
one is about providing text
labels and visual keys to
clarify the visual information.
We saw this earlier.
In my story, I was specifically
missing a visual key.   I just
needed those waves in the   I
can churr to help me understand
--  in the picture to help me
understand the orientation of
the hotel.
Look at this example here.  Take
a couple of moments.   Decide
for yourself what you think
those
icons represent.
Some of them perhaps more
obvious than others  .  You look
at the answer.  Here we go.
It is my trips, book, club,
account.  Did anyone get them
right?
I think problem play accounts
wasn't too bad.  The lesson here
that we saw is again I think it
is over generalizing, you know.
It is like the role we would
give, it is when icons are vague
then they definitely need text
labels.  The trouble is in
saying, you know, when icons are
vague, we all have different
levels of understanding with
regard to that.  You have to, I
think, assume that a lot of your
icons are going to be vague.  I
can give you an example.
You know the icon for filter
that looks kind of like this?
You would think that would be
fairly universal.  It is drawn
in different ways across many
different apps and we didn't
find it universally understood
among people.
I think that we have to, you
know, change our level set with
regard to which -- you know, the
number of icons in our apps
that need to have labels if
people are going to understand
this.  That's a great place to
do simple it testing and to see
the difference between the
providing labels and not
providing labels.
details for when you want to
use text and icons for buttons.
If you have that there.
Talking of labeling things it
makes me aware of majority my
application accessible.  We have
a lot of the guidelines here
for you to make sure that your
application is accessible.
go in today is asking for
permissions in context.  This is
something that we enabled with
Android and it is a significant
number of apps making advantage
of it.  It is possible in I/O
in IoS.  In this   example,
they download, load the app,
they're asked if the location
can be used, this was an app
suggested by someone else, they
said it was a good app if you
want to learn about home decor,
it has it cool things you can
buy.  It is kind of similar to
how we would think of
problematic registration when
you ask for that upfront and it
is a hurdle to get over.  This
is the same thing for users.  It
is like the developer says
provide me with the location
before I give you anything else.
just want to look behind that.
A better way to do that, you can
do that because of Android of N
is doing that with context in
run time.  In this example we
have people searching for a
store, so much better because
the user has their own
motivation, they want to be able
to find that store and then
what happens next is even more
clear for them.  There is a map
that comes up behind and it
allows -- it ask ises can we use
the location.  Of course you
can.
You're much more likely to get
acceptance if you ask in
context.  We have lots of
resources for you for this.  We
have great little videos and
implementation details about
being able to request
permissions in run time.
It is simply in the principals
because although, you know, I
know many of you know about it,
we saw it a lot in the apps that
we studied recently.  That's
why it is here.
That brings me to the end of the
principles I'm going to go
through with you.  We have gone
through each of the tractor
structures and you can
find more online.  They're all
online at thinkwithgoogle and I
made a short link for you here
specifically to the principles,
better mobile user experience.
There is multiple sets of
principles.  There is mobile app
principles, new sets of 25
mobile principles, a new set of
25 principles for retail, both
web and app.   Again we did a
study to create the information
provided from that there.  There
is the mobile web principles
that we have published
previously that you may have
already seen all at this link.
Sameling.
Same link.  If
you want more implementation
details on the mobile
website, that's part of the web
fundamentals site and that
particular link I provided with
you there, it provides
additional developer
implementation details.
Before I go, I want to tell you
about one more story from the
study.     the study a number of
apps had implemented the
ability to scan your credit card
in order to pay.  We had a few
people   in the study that had
used that before, came across
it, liked it.  We had some
people that encountered this for
the first time.  If you think
about the word scan, my most
familiar experience I think with
the word scan is when I go to
the grocery store and I scan my
credit card.   Right.  I'm
putting in my in credit card --
putting it through another
machine.  That's scanning.
Another place I know of the word
scan, it is, you know, putting
paper on a photocopier.  That's
a longer ago.  That's still
scanning, putsing something on
top of each other.
The users come to this request
to scan a credit card.   That's
their use of the word scan.  If
you imagine them trying to
translate that, often the first
thing asked is can we use your
camera.  Well, is the camera
anything to do with scanning my
credit card?  Maybe.  I don't
really understand it, yeah,
okay.  You can use my camera.
credit card here or to scan
automatically.
Following the instructions, no
surprise then we saw three
people in the study do this.
>> (Laughter).
>> JENNIFER GOVE: They waited
and waited.
They thought it sounded like
such a simple way to pay, they
were disappointed.  This is just
about us understanding what
we're asking people to do and
then the language you're using,
it is plain and simple
usability.  We all love this to
work.
Unfortunately, it doesn't work
yet.
It makes sense, right?  What
they were doing.  Because of
what they were told to do.
Again, I return to that point I
made earlier, which is
understanding the user
experience end-to-end,
understanding the flow and the
pain points, really important.
where, you know, you make a
really good app experience for
your users.  Not one where the
user is frustrated and not the
kind of frustration I felt like
after I have used my app and
gone up to my hotel room and
seen that car parked outside of
the window.  I want you to be
able to make app experiences
that makes life feel
frictionless, much like a view
of the beach.  I want to end
with you having three takeaways.
These are three steps that you
can think about doing after
this talk.
Taking a look hat your app and
auditing the app against the 25
principles simply like what are
we do in each experience and is
it measuring up.  That's going
to get you a long, long way.
Your app is unique.  You have to
really understand your key user
journeys and understanding the
breakdown points.  What I have
been provided for my hotel app,
it was really exciting to me,
but it had points that   broke
down for me such that it didn't
end up working well in the end.
your own user testing and this
guide from Google Ventures
provides a lot of resources for
getting going for user research
in a small way so that you can
see the good things you provide